OUR OUR CHILL. AT CAN. WELL
FORGES BRADFORD HAVE I EVER.
CHIANG DALLY. DODD THE RHIZOME
CALGENE. GLAZER GONZALEZ GROVE
HERTZBERG HEY. HUESO. TO JACK.
JOAN LEYVA MCGUIRE MULLIN.
MITCHELL MON. MORE LOCK MORALE
NIELSEN PAN PORTANTINO ROTH
RUBIO INNER STERN I'M BURKE MY
CASKEY WIENER WILK. MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT MEMBERS TODAY
WE HAVE SENATOR BATES
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY WELCOME
SENATOR BATES SENATOR BATES
WILL PARTICIPATE IN DISCUSSION
AND DEBATE BUT WILL NOT BE
PARTICIPATING IN THE QUORUM
CALL OR VOTE MEASURES. WHAT THE
MEMBERS AND OUR GUEST BE ON THE
RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY PLEASE
RISE WILL BE LEAD IN PRAYER
THIS MORNING BY SENATOR
MITCHELL AFTER WHICH PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING WILL BE LED IN
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG BY SENATOR TO ROSS SO
SENATOR MITCHELL. CALLING
BEFORE I BEGIN KNOW THAT SISTER
MICHELLE WHICH IS ALL A SAFE
AND BLESSED RECESS. DODD OF
MANY NAMES AN INFINITE
MANIFESTATIONS IN THE MIDST OF
A GLOBAL PANDEMIC IN GLOBAL
RESISTANCE TO THE PERVASIVE DE
HUMANIZATION OF PERSONS WE ASK
FOR THE GRACE TO STEP UP TO THE
CREATIVE POSSIBILITIES INHERENT
IN THESE CRISES. WE THANK YOU
GOD FOR ALL WE HAVE
ACCOMPLISHED THESE PAST SEVERAL
MONTHS AND WE PRAY THAT WE WILL
NEVER TIRE OF CREATING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA TO SURVIVE AND GROW
AND THRIVE. MAY WE ALL THAT
KNOWLEDGE THAT WE HAVE NOT
NOTICED CAREFULLY ENOUGH OUR
COMPLICITY IN THE I'M JUST
STRUCTURES OF RACISM SEXISM
HETEROSEXISM ABLE LISTEN TO
NAME JUST A FEW. MAY WE NOT BE
OVERCOME WITH GUILT RATHER LET
US BE THE GENERATION THAT
BREAKS THE CHAINS THAT KEEPS US
ALL BOUND IN FEAR. AND
SMALLNESS OF HEART. OUR WORLD
HAS CHANGED DRASTICALLY IN THE
LAST THREE MONTHS DEAR GOD HELP
US COMMIT TO MEETING THE
CHANGES WITH STEADFAST
INTEGRITY DEEP GRATITUDE AND
MANIFEST HOLE AS WE HEAR THE
WORDS OF ALICE WALKER. THE
WORLD HAS CHANGED WAKE UP GIVE
YOURSELF THE GIFT OF A NEW DAY
THE WORLD HAS CHANGED THIS DOES
NOT MEAN YOU WERE NEVER HURT
THE WORLD HAS CHANGED RISE YES
AND SHINE RESIST THE SIREN CALL
OF DISBELIEF THE WORLD HAS
CHANGED DON'T LET YOURSELF
REMAIN ASLEEP TO IT. OUR MAN ON
MAN. RIGHT. OF THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA AND TO READ
FOR WHICH IT SAID. GEN OTHER
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. PRIVILEGES OF
THE FOR THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES
FROM THE WILL DEEMED TO. MISS
FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE
DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED MOVING
TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES. MEMBERS PURSUANT TO
SENATE RULE TWENTY NINE TEN
ITEM TWENTY TWO. THE FOLLOWING
BILLS ARE REFERRED TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE I AM TWENTY TWO AB
ONE ZERO ZERO SEVEN AB TWENTY
THREE. ITEM TWENTY THREE AB
FIVE SEVENTY. I AM TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE ABC FIFTY AND A B.
TEN SIXTY. ITEM TWENTY SIX AND
TWENTY SEVEN AB TWELVE NINETY
NINE AND AB TWELVE FORTY EIGHT.
I AM TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY NINE
AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY IN AB
SEVENTEEN OH NINE. ITEM THIRTY
AND I'M THIRTY ONE A. B. TEN
SIXTY SIX A. B. FIFTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN. ITEM THIRTY TWO A. B.
SEVEN FORTY AND ITEM THIRTY
FOUR AB FOR SIXTY FIVE. YOU'RE
GOOD. WITHOUT OBJECTION THIS
JOURNAL FOR JUNE TWENTY NINE TO
JUNE SECOND TWENTY TWENTY WILL
BE APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK. WITHOUT OBJECTION
MEASURES REPORTED DURING RECESS
WITH AUTHORS AMENDMENTS WILL BE
ADOPTED AND PUBLISHED. SENATOR
MITCHELL FOR WHAT PURPOSE DO
YOU RIDE. NOT A PRO UNDER OF
THEIR- PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I'D LIKE TO SEE A TO
THE JOURNAL. A WITH REGARD TO
SENATE NINETY EIGHT THIS LETTER
TO THE JOURNAL CLARIFIES THE
INTIMATE OF SB NINETY EIGHT THE
K. THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATION
TRAILER BILL WHICH WAS PASSED
BY THE LEGISLATURE AND SIGNED
BY THE GOVERNOR. ASSEMBLY THE
LETTER CLARIFIES THE INTENT OF
THE LEGISLATURE THAT LAYOFF
NOTICES ISSUE TO CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES. BETWEEN MAY SECOND
TWENTY TWENTY. AND JULY FIRST
OF TWENTY TWENTY. OUR TO BE
IMPLEMENTED BECAUSE THE SIXTY
DAY NOTICE PERIOD CONCLUDES
AFTER JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY.
SB NINETY EIGHT AS A REMINDER
PROHIBITS CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES
IN POSITIONS RELATED TO
NUTRITION TRANSPORTATION ECO
STONE HILL DUTIES FROM BEING
LAID OFF AFTER JULY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY. THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL CENTER JONES FOR A
PURPOSE TO RISE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- WE RECEIVED THE
LETTER WITH LATE NOTICE AND I.
WOULD LIKE TO ASK FOR ROLL CALL
VOTE ON THE SUBMISSION TO THE
JOURNAL PLEASE ABSOLUTELY THANK
YOU CENTER JONES MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ARCHULETA. I AT I BELL.
FORGES NO BRADFORD. I HAVE A HI.
DALLY NO DODD. I THE RISING I
GALGIANI I GLAZER. I GONZALEZ.
I GROWTH NO HERTZBERG. HI HILL
I WITH AYE HURTADO HI JACK'S. I
JONES. LEYVA I MCGUIRE AYE
MULLIN. NO MITCHELL HI MONNING
I MORE LOCK NO MORALE. IN
NIELSEN NO HAN. I FORCE. I ROTH.
RUBY I SKINNER I STERN AYE
NUMBER HI Y. CASKEY I WIENER.
HI WILK NO. PLEASE THE AROUND
THE NO. ALLEN BELL I CAN.
MORALE ROTH. SIZE TWENTY SEVEN
KNOWS EIGHT THE LETTER WILL BE
SUBMITTED TO THE JOURNAL
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING ON TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
SENATE THIRD READING ITEM
SIXTEEN SENATOR HANNAH BETH
JACKSON ARE YOU READY I AM VERY
GOOD MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE BY SENATOR JACKSON
AN ACT RELATING TO EMPLOYMENT
CENTER JACKSON GOOD MORNING
MADAM PRESIDENT CALLING SO I
JUST GOT A TEXT FROM MY HUSBAND
WHO TOLD ME THAT. HE AND MY TWO
GRANDCHILDREN ARE WATCHING
RIGHT NOW SO I SHOULD FEEL NO
PRESSURE WHATSOEVER- SO- WITH
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO START AND
WE SURE EVERYBODY- THE TOP OF
THE MORNING. I AM HONORED TODAY.
TO PRESENT THE SB. THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE. THE FAMILY LEAVE
BUDGET BILL. THIS IS PART OF
THE BUDGET AGREEMENT REACHED BY
THE GOVERNOR AND LEGISLATIVE
LEADERSHIP. THIS IS AN AREA
WHERE I HAVE BEEN WORKING FOR
THE PAST EIGHT YEARS DURING MY
TENURE HERE IN THE SENATE SO I
AM PARTICULARLY PLEASED TO BE
ABLE TO PRESENT THIS HERE
TODAY. BECAUSE IF THERE IS ONE
PREDICTABLE EXPERIENCE IN LIFE
IT IS THAT WE WILL AT SOME
POINT NEED TO CARE FOR OUR
LOVED ONES OR BE THERE TO HELP.
THE FIRST FEW MONTHS OF A
NEWBORN'S LIFE. DEAL WITH
PARENTS WHO ARE ILL. OR HAVE
OUR CHILDREN CARE FOR US AS WE
AGE. AND SO THIS BILL
STRENGTHENS THE IMPORTANT LAW
KNOWN AS THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY
RIGHT CHECKED WHICH PROVIDES
THE JOB PROTECTION FOUNDATION
FOR OUR STATE PAID FAMILY LEAVE
WAGE REPLACEMENT PROGRAM. SO
WHAT IS THIS WE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WITH THE IRST IN
THE NATION TO CREATE A PROGRAM
BY WHICH PEOPLE COULD. TAKE
LEAVE THAT WOULD BE PAID FOR.
THE PROGRAM REQUIRES THE
EMPLOYEE. TO PUT MONEY IN TO
THAT PROGRAM NOT THE EMPLOYER
SO WHEN YOU TAKE FAMILY LEAVE
YOU ARE ESSENTIALLY CALLING IN
THE SAVINGS ACCOUNT THAT YOU
HAVE CREATED. WE HAVE NOW IN
CALIFORNIA'S SIX WEEKS OF
PARTIALLY PUT PAID WAY
REPLACEMENT IT WILL BE GOING UP
TO EIGHT WEEKS IN JANUARY. WELL
THAT'S GREAT BUT THE PROBLEM IS
THAT FOR TOO MANY CALIFORNIANS.
CAN TAKE THAT LEAVE THAT THEY
HAVE AND GET REIMBURSED BOARD.
GET PAID OUT OF THEIR OWN
SAVINGS ACCOUNT A PARTIAL WAGE
REPLACEMENT. BUT THERE IS NO
ASSURANCE THAT THEIR JOB WILL
BE THERE WHEN THEY RETURN. WHAT
THIS BILL IS TODAY IS THE OTHER
HALF OF THAT EQUATION. THE HALF
OF THAT EQUATION THAT ASSURES
PEOPLE WHEN THEY TAKE THE LEAD
THEY ARE ENTITLED TO TAKE.
THEIR JOB WILL BE THERE WHEN
THEY COME BACK. BECAUSE WHAT
HAPPENS IS PEOPLE DON'T TAKE
THE LEAVE BECAUSE THEY'RE
AFRAID THEY'RE GONNA LOSE THEIR
JOB. THAT IS A HOBSON'S CHOICE
A SOPHIE'S CHOICE. EITHER YOU
TAKE BELIEVE THAT YOU'RE
ENTITLED TO. OR YOU LOSE YOUR
JOB BECAUSE YOU'VE DONE THAT.
THAT IS WRONG. THAT MAKES IT
DIFFICULT IF NOT POSSIBLE FOR
PEOPLE TO BE PAYMENT BEINGS. TO
HAVE TO CHOOSE BETWEEN WHETHER
THEY'RE GOING TO CARE FOR A
SICK FAMILY MEMBER OR THEIR OWN
HEALTH. OR HAVE A JOB WHEN
THEY'RE DONE. THAT'S JUST A
CRUEL AND INHUMAN. APPROACH TO
PEOPLE HAVING NEEDS TO CARE FOR
FAMILY BECAUSE WE ARE ALL HUMAN
BEINGS AND I WILL POSH AT THAT.
THOSE OF US WHO HAVE NOT YET
HAD THAT RESPONSIBILITY WILL AT
SOME POINT HAVE THAT
RESPONSIBILITY. TO CARE FOR
THEMSELVES. IF THEY BECOME ILL
OR TO CARE FOR A LOVED ONE OR
TO HAVE A FAMILY. AND BE ABLE
BOTH MEN AND WOMEN TO BE THERE
DURING THOSE CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT EARLY TIMES WHICH WE
KNOW BY THE WAY. ARE BENEFICIAL
NOT ONLY TO THE INFANT BUT ALSO
TO THE MOTHER REDUCES POST
PARTUM DEPRESSION BY A THIRD.
IT ALSO CREATES A LIFETIME BOND
WITH A NEW FATHER. NOW 25% OF
THE PEOPLE TODAY. WHO HAVE NEW
CHECK A FAMILIES CAN'T ACCESS
THAT LEAVE. THIS BILL WILL
CORRECT THAT IT'S SIX TO CLOSE
THE CARE GIVING GAP THAT HIS
EXISTED FOR FAR TOO LONG
CREATING AN UNCONSCIONABLE
DIVIDE BETWEEN THOSE WHO CAN
TAKE THE TIME OFF BECAUSE THEY
WORK FOR AN EMPLOYER OF A
HIGHER NUMBER AND THOSE WHO
CAN'T SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY WORK
FOR AN EMPLOYER OF A LESSER.
NUMBER THERE IS NO CONNECTION
BETWEEN THE NEED TO CARE FOR
FAMILY AND THE EMPLOYER THAT
YOU WORK FOR. WHY SHOULD THERE-BE THAT DISTINCTION THERE
SHOULD NOT. AND I BELIEVE IT IS
EVEN MORE IMPORTANT TO CLOSE
THAT GAP DURING THIS PANDEMIC.
AFTER ALL WE WANT THOSE TO STAY
HOME SO THEY DON'T INFECT
OTHERS. WE NEED FAMILY CARE
GIVING TO HELP PEOPLE- TO HELP
PREVENT HOSPITALIZATIONS AND
GOD FOR BID NURSING HOME
PLACEMENTS NURSING HOMES THE
DEATH TOTAL OF ALL OUR CODE
PATIENTS AS A RESULT OF NURSING
HOME INFECTION IS 43% OF ALL
CODED RELATED DEATHS TO THIS
DATE. ART NURSING HOMES. PEOPLE
ABILITY CARE FOR THEIR LOVED
ONES IT REDUCES NURSING HOME
NEEDS BY 11% RIGHT OFF THE BAT.
NOW THE UNITED STATES. THE
SHAMEFULLY THE ONLY
INDUSTRIALIZED AND WEALTHY
NATION IN THE WORLD. WITHOUT A
NATIONAL PAID FAMILY LEAVE
PROGRAM. STATE INSTEAD HAVE
BEEN FORCED TO FILL THE VOID
AND AS I MENTIONED SIXTEEN
YEARS AGO CALIFORNIA ENACTED
WHAT WAS THEN THE FIRST PAID
FAMILY LEAVE PROGRAM AGAIN
ENTIRELY WORKER FUNDED. THE
EMPLOYEE DOES NOT PAY A DIME
INTO THEIR PROGRAM. BUT FROM
THE BEGINNING AS I MENTIONED
FOR TWO WORKERS WERE EXCLUDED
FROM THOSE PROTECTIONS BECAUSE
THEY'RE BASED ON THE SIZE OF
THE EMPLOYER JOB PROTECTED TIME
UNDER A FAMILY RIGHT CHECK FOR
CARE GIVING AND TAKING OFF FOR
ONE'S OWN ILLNESS EXCLUDES UP
TO FORTY FORTY FOUR ZERO
PERCENT. OF THE WORKFORCE. AND
THIS HAS FORCED THEIR TERRIBLE
CHOICE. RESEARCH TELLS US THE
PAID FAMILY LEAVE TAKEN FOR
FAMILY CARE GIVING DECREASES
HOSPITALIZATIONS MEDICAL COSTS
AND OF COURSE THAT MAKES SENSE
BECAUSE YOU'RE ABLE TO STAY
HOME AND TAKE CARE YOURSELF OR
TAKE YOUR YOUR LOVED ONES. SO
THAT THE ILLNESS OF THE DISEASE
OR WHATEVER IT IS DOESN'T GET
WORSE RESULTING IN THOSE
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND MEDICAL
COSTS RESEARCH TELLS US THAT
BIG BABY BONDING AS I MENTIONED
THE CREASES POST PARTUM
DEPRESSION AND THE OTHER ITEMS
THAT I MENTIONED. NOW WITH
RESEARCH LIKE THIS WE SHOULD BE
DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN DO TO
REMOVE THE BARRIERS TO THIS
FAMILY LEAVE. THAT'S WHAT SB
EIGHT AT THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
DOES IT STRENGTHENS THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY RIGHT CHECK
AND GUARANTEES TWELVE WEEKS OF
UNPAID JOB PROTECTED LEAVE TO
CARE FOR A NEWBORN. A SERIOUSLY
ILL FAMILY MEMBER OR ONE'S OWN
ILLNESS FOR THOSE WHO WORK FOR
EMPLOYEES OF FIVE EMPLOYEES OR
MORE. IT PROVIDES JOB PROTECTED
BENEFITS THEN FOR NINETY TWO
PERCENT. OF CALIFORNIA'S
WORKFORCE. THIS BILL A LARGE
DEAF OF FAMILY WITHIN THE
FAMILY RIGHT TO ACT AND THE
PAID FAMILY LEAVE PROGRAM. TO
ALLOW FOR CARE FOR GRANDPARENTS.
GRAND CHILDREN ADULT CHILDREN
IN LAWS AND SIBLINGS.
CALIFORNIA IS THE SECOND MOST
MULTI GENERATIONAL STATE IN THE
COUNTRY. WE CARE FOR OUR LOVED
ONES IN MANY INSTANCES WE LIVE
WITH OUR GRANDPARENTS FOR OUR
GRANDCHILDREN OR IN LAWS OR WE
ARE RESPONSIBLE PARTIES FOR
THEIR HEALTH AND WELL BEING
BECAUSE THERE IS NOBODY ELSE.
THIS BILL ALSO CONNECTS A ONE
MILLION DOLLAR APPROPRIATION IN
THE BUDGET. CREATING A PROGRAM
TO PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR BOWL OF
SMALL BUSINESSES WHOSE
EMPLOYEES TAKE THIS LEAVE. AND
THE BILL WAS RECENTLY AMENDED
TO EXEMPT VERY SMALL BUSINESSES
OF FOR EMPLOYEES OR LESS FROM
THESE REQUIREMENTS WE ALSO
DIFFER IMPLEMENTATION TO
JANUARY. WHICH IS PART OF THE
ISSUE HERE IT'S NOW DEFERRED.
IT'S STILL THE RECALL THAT AN
EMPLOYEE HAS WORKED FOR AN
EMPLOYER FOR ONE YEAR AND AT
LEAST TWELVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
HOURS IN ORDER TO. BE ABLE TO
APPLY AND THE QUALIFY. NOW
SIGNIFICANT DELIBERATIONS HAVE
GONE INTO THIS PROPOSAL THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF STUDIES THAT
HAVE BEEN- PERFORMED THERE'S A
STUDY RECENTLY FROM STANFORD A
STUDY FROM THE BUDGET- GROUPS.
THAT ARE KNOWN FOR THEIR
CAREFUL PRECISE OBJECTIVE WORK
IN THESE AREAS. IT IS THE FIRST
RECOMMENDATION PUT FORWARD BY
THE GOVERNOR'S PAID FAMILY
LEAVE TASK FORCE WHICH WAS A
STAKEHOLDER GROUP DRIVEN BY
RESEARCH THAT MEN FROM MATT FOR
MONTHS. AND INCLUDED BUSINESS
LABOR EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
QUIRK AND FAMILY ADVOCATES AND
OTHERS. NOW. I KNOW THERE'S
OPPOSITION TO THIS ARM I DO NOT
BELIEVE THAT THE POINTS THAT
ARE- PRESENTED ARE VALID- BUT
CERTAINLY I HAVE EVERY REASON
TO BELIEVE WE WILL HEAR THEM
TODAY AND- I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE OF THE
CONCERNS- THE OPPOSITION IF I'M
NOT MISTAKEN MUCH TO THINK OF
THIS IS SOME EXTREME PROGRAM
THEY'RE ALREADY FIVE STATES IN
THE COUNTRY TO GO DOWN TO ZERO.
YEAH SHE- PROVIDING ENJOY
PROTECTION FOR THEM WE HAVE HAD
A THE STATE. WE'VE HAD IN THE
STATE XIN XIN SEVENTY EIGHT.
ARE PREGNANT SHE DISABILITY
LEAVE FOR COMPANIES OF FIVE OR
MORE THAT'S FORTY TWO YEARS
THIS PROGRAM HAS WORKED. THIS
ROGRAM HAS NOT RESULTED IN
PROFLIGATE LIT LITIGATION. OUR
THIS IS THE KIND OF THING THAT
FAMILIES IN THIS COUNTRY. AND
IN THE STATE ARE DESPERATELY IN
NEED OFF BECAUSE A GOOD
EMPLOYEE ONE WHO IS GIVEN
RESPECT AND THE KNOWLEDGE TO
HAVE A LIFE OUTSIDE OF WORK IS
A BETTER EMPLOYEE THE DATA ALL
SHOWS IT AND OF COURSE WHEN YOU
RETAIN EMPLOYEES YOU SAVE
MONEY. YOU DON'T HAVE TO
RETAINING YOU DON'T HAVE TO GO
OUT AND SEEK NEW EMPLOYEES. I
MEAN THIS IS A WIN WIN FOR BOTH
SIDES IT IS DEFINITELY A
CULTURE CHANGE AND I APPRECIATE
THAT. BUT THE FACT IS WE HAVE
SEEN. PORTIONS OF THAT OVER THE
COURSE OF THE LAST FORTY TWO
YEARS WE HAVE SEEN WHEN WE DID
THE NEW PARENT LEAVE ACT IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. THE BENEFITS
FOR BOTH MEN AND WOMEN. AND DO
SIMPLY EXTENDS THOSE BENEFITS
RECOGNIZING OUR COMMON HUMANITY
AND THE NEED THAT WE HAVE TO BE
THERE FOR OUR LOVED ONES TO
TAKE CARE OF OUR OWN HEALTH.
AND TO BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE REARING OF OUR FAMILIES
AND OUR CHILDREN. AND WITH THAT
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FEAR I
FELT. THANK YOU SENATOR
JACKSON. MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND
OR DEBATE SENATOR SKINNER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND I
WANT TO THANK OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM SANTA BARBARA FOR REALLY-
WELL PRESENTED BACKGROUND ON
THIS BILL AND ALSO FOR HER LONG
LONG WORK ON THIS AND
COMMITMENT TO THIS ISSUE. WHEN
I WHAT HAD MY DAUGHTER. IN THE
EARLY EIGHTIES THERE WAS NO
PAID FAMILY LEAVE. SO I TOOK MY
TWO WEEKS OF SICK LEAVE I
WORKED TILL JUST. COUPLE DAYS
BEFORE SHE WAS BORN. I THEN
WENT BACK TO WORK SO I THINK I
HAD TWO WEEKS TO SICK LEAVE IT
SO I WENT BACK TO WORK WHEN SHE
WAS. JUST UNDER TWO WEEKS OLD.
MAYBE JUST AT TWO WEEKS I
BROUGHT HER TO WORK. NOBODY'S
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING MOST
PEOPLE CAN DO. HOW I HAD A JOB
THAT ALLOWED ME TO DO IT IS
QUITE REMARKABLE AND I WAS
QUITE FORTUNATE WITHOUT THAT I
DON'T KNOW WHAT I WOULD HAVE
DONE. WE KNOW THAT SO MANY
FAMILIES FACE THIS I DID NOT
HAVE TO FACE TAKING CARE OF
EITHER OF MY PARENTS BECAUSE
MOST UNFORTUNATELY TEY DIED.
QUITE A LONG TIME AGO. BUT IF I
NEEDED TO NOW AND IF WE HAD NO
PAID FAMILY LEAVE. WHAT
SITUATION WOULD I BE IT FOR ANY
OF US. AND AS OUR COLLEAGUE
POINTED OUT. AS THE EMPLOYEE WE
ARE PAYING INTO THE SYSTEM WE
HAVE ALREADY MADE A DEPOSIT
INTO IT AND WHAT THIS REALLY
DES AS SHE'S SO WELL DESCRIBED
IS GUARANTEE THAT WE CAN HAVE A
JOB WHEN WE RETURN SO IN MY
SITUATION I COULD HAVE. TAKEN A
LITTLE MORE TIME BOTH TO
RECOVER FROM THE BIRTH ENTER OF
TAKING CARE OF MY DAUGHTER AND-
THEN I COULD HAVE RETURNED TO
WORK KNOWING THAT MY JOB WAS
THERE INSTEAD OF TAKING A TWO
WEEK OLD TO A JOB EVERY DAY
WHICH I WILL TELL YOU RIGHT
NOW. WAS INSANITY. SO THIS IS A
VERY NEEDED POLICY. AND AS THE
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR- WHEN WE
LAST TOOK THIS UP. TALKED
ABOUT. WE ARE REALLY THE ONLY-
E. C. D. COUNTRIES. THE DOES
NOT HAVE SUCH A POLICY. UNITED
STATES THE ONLY. AND
UNFORTUNATELY WHILE THIS
AFFECTS EVERYONE MEN WOMEN ANY
GENDER. WHAT IS IT THE LACK OF
THIS POLICY HAS MOST IMPACTED
WOMEN'S ABILITY TO MOVE UP
ECONOMICALLY AND TO MOVE IN THE
WORK FORCE. AND THAT IS NOT
APPROPRIATE AT THIS POINT SO I
REALLY STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE BY VIRGIN AYE VOTE AND
I THINK THE GOOD SENATOR FOR
FROM SANTA BARBARA AND I THINK
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR
INSISTING TO MOVE THIS FORWARD
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTER GET
CENTER WIENER. BUT YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM IRA AND SUPPORT OF-
US SENATE BILL THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE AND I ALSO WANT TO
RELEASE MY DEEP CREDIT. TO THE
CENTER OF THE SANTA BARBARA FOR
HER DOG AND PURSUE OF A
RATIONAL. AND WORKABLE AND JOSS
PAID FAMILY LEAVE APPROACH
INSTEAD OF CALIFORNIA. YOU KNOW
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE DATA AND
THIS. OF PAID FAMILY AND
FOUNDER POLICY AROUND WORLD. IT
IS DEEPLY MORTIFYING THAT THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA IS SO
FAR BEHIND OTHER NATIONS IN
MOST PARTS OF THE WORLD IN MANY
PARTS OF THE WORLD THIS IS NOT
CONTROVERSIAL. THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING WHERE WE HAVE TO HAVE
A FIGHT EVERY TIME YOU TRY TO
IMPLEMENT. FAMILY LEAVE IT'S
CONSIDERED AS BASIC AS NORMAL
THAT OF COURSE WHEN SOMEONE HAS
A NEW CHILD OR HAS A SIX SPOUSE
AT HOME OR HAS A SICK CHILD OF
COURSE. YOU CAN STAY HOME AND
TAKE CARE OF THAT PERSON.
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
FRANKLY OF A SAFETY NET IN
GENERAL AND FAMILY MEMBERS HAVE
TO BE THERE FOR OTHER FAMILY
MEMBERS WHETHER IT'S A NEW
CHILD OR SICK FAMILY MEMBERS
AND THE IDEA THAT WE CONTINUE.
TO FORCE. SOMETHING LIKE FORTY
PERCENT.OF CALIFORNIA WORKERS
TO THE SIDE ARE YOU GOING TO
CARE FOR YOUR NEW CHILD. OR
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE A JOB. ARE
YOU GOING TO CARE FOR YOUR SICK
PARENT OR YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
A JOB. AND THAT'S THE CHOICE
THAT WE ARE FORCING. ON
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIA WORKERS
EVERY SINGLE DAY AND LET'S BE
CRYSTAL CLEAR ABOUT WHO THOSE
WORKERS ARE. IT'S NOT EQUALLY
SPREAD AMONG ALL WORKERS THIS
IS DISPROPORTIONATELY
DRAMATICALLY HARMING. LOW
INCOME WORKERS SERVICE WORKERS
LOWER PAID WOMEN. WHO ARE OFTEN
THE ONES WHO ARE FORCED INTO
THAT TERRIBLE CHOICE. AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR THIS IS
NOT EQUALLY SPREAD. AND WHAT WE
ARE ASKING IS TO HAVE MORE
EQUITY SO THAT PEOPLE DON'T
HAVE TO MAKE THAT TERRIBLE
CHOICE AND COVERT OF COURSE HAS
AS IT IS DONE IN MANY. ASPECTS
OF SOCIETY HAS CAST A HUGE
SPOTLIGHT ON THIS TERRIBLE
INEQUITY WHERE PEOPLE AGAIN ARE
BEING FORCED TO CHOOSE DO I
TAKE CARE OF MY FAMILY MEMBER.
OR DO I HAVE A JOB. WHEN I WAS
A MEMBER OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS WE WERE
ABLE TO PASS EXPANDED PAID
PARENTAL LEAVE. LEGISLATION AND
I WILL TELL YOU COLLEAGUES THE
NUMBER OF WORKERS IN THE YEARS
SINCE THEN WHO HAVE COME UP TO
ME ON THE STREET OR AT A
RESTAURANT OR ELSEWHERE. AND
THANKED ME ANDMY COLLEAGUES
FROM THE BOTTOM OF THEIR HEART.
BECAUSE THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT
THEY WOULD HAVE DONE OTHERWISE
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE STRUGGLING
WITH THESE TERRIBLE DECISIONS
THAT ARE NECESSARY DECISIONS.
TODAY'S LEGISLATION SP THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE WILL HELP
ELIMINATE THAT TERRIBLE. FOR
CALLING THIS IS YOU KNOW I IT
THESE ISSUES AND THIS LEASE OR
ALWAYS. BUT WHEN YOU. AT THE
BASIC ISSUE THIS IS A BASIC
MORAL DECISION. TO SHOULD THE
UNITED STATES FOR CALIFORNIA.
BE DOING WHAT SO MUCH OF THE
REST OF THE WORLD IS DOING TO
TREAT THESE WORKERS TO TREAT
THESE FAMILIES FAIRLY. AND TO.
AND TO THAT TERRIBLE CHOICE
BETWEEN CARING FOR A FAMILY
MEMBER. AND HAVING A JOB I
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU SENATOR WIENER CENTERED.
THANK YOU A- MADAM PRESIDENT.
I'M GONNA HAVE A LITTLE BIT FOR
DIFFERENT TO TAKE ON THIS PIECE
OF LEGISLATION I THINK THEN
MAYBE A LOT OF OTHERS ON THE
FLOOR BUT- I WANT TO SHARE A-
THIS IS THE AUTHOR THIS BILL.
BROUGHT A BILL A FEW YEARS BACK
SB SIXTY THREE. AND I WAS ONE
OF THE- THREE REPUBLICANS IN
THE ASSEMBLY THAT SUPPORTED
THAT BILL I THINK THAT THERE IT
WAS A RIGHTEOUS BILL AND IT WAS
ALSO IN THE SAME AREA BUT I
WANT TO SHARE WITH THE MEMBERS
AND LEGISLATORS OF THIS BODY.
I'VE BEEN IN THIS LEGISLATOR
FOR A IN THIS LEGISLATURE FOR
EIGHT YEARS. AND IN THIS EIGHT
YEARS. I CAME TO THE
LEGISLATURE BECAUSE I'M A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER AND WE REALLY
AREN'T REPRESENTED. HERE WE
DON'T HAVE ALL THE SMALL
BUSINESSES DON'T REALLY HAVE A
PACK AND THEY'RE THEY'RE BUSY
RUNNING THEIR BUSINESSES AND
THE LIGHTS AND I DON'T HAVE
MORE THAN FIVE EMPLOYEES I THE
MOST I'VE EVER HAD IS FOR- SO
THIS BILL IS A GOOD IN FACT
AFFECT MY BUSINESS BUT IT'S
GONNA FACT. FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA. ACCORDING TO THE
INFORMATION I COULD GATHER. AND
THERE'S BEEN TALK ABOUT THE
COST THERE IS NO COST WELL
THERE IS A COST TO THIS PIECE
OF LEGISLATION. ACOSTA TRAINING.
SOMEBODY TO REPLACE THEM YOU
CAN TAKE THIS LEAVE AN- HOUR
INCREMENTS. IF YOU HAVE A
BUSINESS WITH FIVE EMPLOYEES
AND ONE EMPLOYEE IS THE
OPERATOR OR A MAIN POSITION IN
YOUR COMPANY THAT. YOU CAN'T
REPLACE THAT MAKES THE OTHER
FOR POSITIONS WORK. AND THEY'RE
GONE FOR A LONG TIME IT'S GOING
TO BE DIFFICULT. AND YOU KNOW
WE'VE WE'VE HEARD ABOUT YOU
ABOUT A LOT TO BE THERE THERE'S
NOT BEEN ONE PIECE THE STATION
I CAN RECALL EIGHT YEARS THAT
I'VE HERE THAT ACTUALLY HELP MY
BUSINESS. WE'VE HAD MINIMUM
WAGE INCREASE AND WE'RE GOING
TO YEAH WE'RE GOING TO DO YOU A
FAVOR WE'RE GOING TO. PHASE IT
IN OVERTIME. WE USED TO HAVE AN
EXEMPTION FOR AG THAT WE WERE
ABLE TO. NOT HAVE TO PAY
OVERTIME UP TO SIXTY HOURS. AND
IT WAS FOR WHEN WE HARVESTED.
AND WE PLANTED. THAT THAT'S
BEEN TAKEN AWAY. AB FIVE YOU
CAN'T EVEN NOW CONTRACT WITH
SOMEBODY TO REPLACE THIS
EMPLOYEE IT'S GOING TO TAKE
THIS TIME OUT BECAUSE IT AB
FIVE AND IN MY BUSINESS WHERE
WE HAVE A WE HAVE A TRUCKING
BUSINESS IF MY PLAYERS YOU
LEAVE AS I MENTIONED THE OTHER
NIGHT WHEN WE WERE HERE. TILL
MIDNIGHT TAKING. THE TESTIMONY
ON THE BUDGET. THAT'S A
POSITION THAT HAS. A SPECIAL
LICENSE IS IN A DRUG PROGRAM.
HAS HOURS OF SERVICE MANY
QUALIFICATIONS FOR THAT THERE
ARE MILLION SHORT IN THIS STATE
FOR TRUCK DRIVERS SO TO REPLACE
A TRUCK DRIVER UNDER THIS LAW
WOULD BE VERY DIFFICULT. AND IN
AND A TIME WHEN WE'VE SEEN
BUSINESSES LAY OFF SHUT DOWN
BECAUSE OF CODE BUT I THINK
THIS IS ANOTHER HIT. TO
BUSINESSES. YOU KNOW I FIND IT
INTERESTING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE. PASSES ALL KINDS
OF LAWS TO REGULATE MY BUSINESS
AND THEY DON'T EVEN ABIDE BY
THE LAWS. THE DAY PASS. THIS
LEGISLATURE RIGHT HERE DID NOT
PAY OVERTIME TO THE EMPLOYEES
THAT WERE HERE TILL MIDNIGHT
THE OTHER NIGHT. WHY IS THAT
WHY DON'T WE DO IT LEASE ABIDE
BY THE SAME LAWS. BUT EVERYBODY
ELSE HAS TO WE ARE RIGHT WE HAD
A BILL IN THE ASSEMBLY THIS
SAID THAT A YOU KNOW THE
LEGISLATOR SAID NO WE'RE
SPECIAL. WELL I PUT FOOD ON THE
TABLE FOR AMERICANS I THINK
THAT'S KIND OF SPECIAL TO. I
WANT TO ASK YOU ALL OF YOU ON
YOUR DESK. HAVE A BOTTLE. I
BELIEVE A LITTLE BROWN BOTTLE.
NOW IN MY BUSINESS I'M
REGULATED BY PROPOSITION SIXTY
FIVE. WHAT'S IN THIS BOTTLE DO
YOU KNOW CAN ANYBODY TELL ME
WHAT IS IN THIS BOTTLE. THERE'S
NO LABEL ON IT. THIS IN MY
BUSINESS WOULD BE CONSIDERED
SOMETHING I COULD GET SUED OVER
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S IN
THIS BOTTLE. THERE'S NO LABEL
ON. BUT WE DON'T ABIDE BY THOSE
RULES WHAT ABOUT EMPLOYEES IN
THIS HOUSE THE DON'T HAVE TO
ABIDE BY THE SAME RULES YOU
KNOW IT'S JUST VERY FRUSTRATING
AS A LEGISLATOR TO HAVE TO HEAR.
HOW BAD WE ARE AS EMPLOYERS TO
EMPLOYEES WE DON'T NEED THE
GOVERNMENT TO GET IN THE WAY OF
OUR EMPLOYEES AND OUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH OUR EMPLOYEES.
MY WIFE MEGAN WAS PREGNANT AND
WORKING AT THE TIME WE HAD OUR
FIRST CHILD AND SHE WORKED FOR
A COMPANY. THERE WAS NO
PROBLEMS YEAH ALL THE TIMES
NEEDED OFF AND ACTUALLY PATER.
WE ONE OF OUR EMPLOYEES WE HAVE
A RELATIONSHIP WITH THEM WE
DON'T NEED THE BURDENSOME
REGULATIONS OF GOVERNMENT TO
TELL US HOW TO. WORK WITH OUR
EMPLOYEES AND WHAT IS JUST AND
RIGHT. IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO
GET GOOD EMPLOYEES SO WHEN YOU
GET THEM YOU WANT TO TAKE CARE
OF THEM. MEMBERS I AM VERY
FRUSTRATED FOR THE FACT THAT I
CAME HERE TO TRY TO SPEAK. FOR
THOSE WHO DON'T. HAVE A LOBBY
IN AN ART ORGANIZED AND THAT'S
THE SMALL BUSINESSES OF
CALIFORNIA. AND I HEARD YOU TO
THINK ABOUT. THE BURDEN IS
GOING TO PUT ON THE BUSINESSES
TO CROSS TRAIN IT TO FIND THOSE.
AT A TIME WHEN WE'VE SEEN
MASSIVE LAYOFFS. I URGE NO VOTE
ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU SENATOR
DOLLY CENTER GROVE. AS IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL AS WELL
BUT I DO HAVE A QUESTION OF THE
AUTHOR SHE COULD POSSIBLY
ANSWER IT THAT MIGHT BE
HELPFUL. SENATE JACKSON ARE YOU
WILLING TO TAKE OF A QUESTION
I'D BE HAPPY TO TAKE IT AND
RESPOND TO IT IN MY CLOTHES.
AND MY QUESTION IS THAT IS IN
THE LANGUAGE IT'S NOT
CONSECUTIVE. SO IT'S NOT TWELVE
WEEKS CONSECUTIVE. THE LANGUAGE
IN THE BILL SAYS IT'S NOT
CONSECUTIVE. CONSECUTIVE
MEANING TWELVE WEEKS SO SOMEONE
HAS A BABY LIKE YOU EXPLAINED
THE NEED TO TAKE CARE OF LEVEL
ONE. THIS IS NOT TWELVE WEEKS
CONSECUTIVE. I REALIZE THAT YOU
HAVE TO BE THERE YEAR TWELVE
HUNDRED FIFTY HOURS WHICH IS
BASICALLY TWENTY FOUR HOURS A
WEEK FOR FIFTY TWO WEEKS. THE
TIME I. CONSECUTIVE SO. A
FORTY. SEND TO TAKE. AS
ACTUALLY TWENTY FOUR WEEKS AT
TWENTY HOURS A DAY OUR TWENTY
HOURS A WEEK. OR YOU COULD TAKE
OFF EVERY FRIDAY FOR FIFTY TWO
WEEKS OR YOU COULD TAKE US. AND
YOU KNOW INTERMITTENT IT
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE CONSISTENT-
CONSECUTIVE. SO FOLLOWING UP ON
THAT'S MY QUESTION TO CONFIRM
THAT IT'S NOT CONSECUTIVE
CANCELING WHICH IS A STATE OUT
AND THEN THE FOLLOW UP ON MY
OWN TIME WITH MY COLLEAGUES
FROM BEAVER. THE BUSINESS OWNER
I TO KEEP MY PEER THINKING
THAT. IF I JUST DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU WERE DOING
WITH BUSINESS WHEN YOU PASSED
ALL THESE RULES AND REGULATIONS
THAT STOPPED US FROM PLAIN
PEOPLE AND MAKING PEOPLE
GAINFULLY EMPLOYED TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE FOR THEIR FAMILIES.
WHEN I GOT HERE IT ONLY TOOK ME
ABOUT THIRTY DAYS TO FIGURE OUT
THAT YOU DO UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE DOING TO SMALL BUSINESS
AND TO BUSINESS OWNERS AND JOB
CREATORS AND THE STATE. AND YOU
JUST FRANKLY DON'T CARE- IT'S
VERY FRUSTRATING LIKE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BEAVER SAYS TO
BE A BUSINESS CENTER IN THIS
STATE AND TRY TO PROVIDE
GAINFULLY EMPLOYED PETE. SO
THAT THEY CAN PROVIDE FOR THEIR
FAMILIES. AND THEN HAVE
REGULATORY PROCESS AFTER
REGULATORY PROCESS INCREASES IN
MINIMUM WAGE YOU MENTIONED THE
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES AND
ALSO HIGH AFTER THE SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES BECAUSE
ABOUT 60% OF THE FATALITIES IN
MY DISTRICT THAT AFFECT. US
BEING OPEN IN MY COMMUNITY ARE
FROM STATE STATE REGULATED AND
STATE LICENSED THAT ELDERLY
CARE FACILITY SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES. AND THEY NEED TO BE
TAKEN CARE OF AND GIVEN A
QUALITY LIFE ESPECIALLY AT THE
TIME OF LIFE IF THEY'RE IN. IT
WHEN YOU LOOK AT. THAT THAT
PARTICULAR STATEMENT THAT YOU
MADE ABOUT CARING FOR ELDERLY
PEOPLE. AND IN THIS WOULD THAT
WE NEED TO MAKE THE ELDER OR TO
CARE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT A
PARENT BONDS WITH THE CHILD.
BUT WE ALSO MAKES IS. PROVIDE
1% RED IT COMES TO THIS. ONLY
COME FROM BUSINESS. NO YOU GUYS
THAT'S HOW. THE FACT. THE
BUSINESS OR PRIVATE BIZ OR
REQUIRE PERMITS PRIVATE BIZ ARE
YOU TAX PRIVATE BUSINESS ANY
AND AT THE THAT THEY EMPLOY AND
THEN DOES EMPLOYEES GO OUT BY
PRODUCT WHICH PAY TAXES ON SO
IT'S ALL GENERATED FROM PRIVATE
BUSINESS INTO TO DETRIMENTALLY
HARM PRIVATE BUSINESS
ESPECIALLY SMALL BUSINESS AND
NOT HAVE. A LANGUAGE IN THERE
TO WEAR NOT EVERY EMPLOYEE
THERE WILL BE EMPLOYEES THAT
WILL TAKE THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION AND HAVE A BABY BE
GONE TWELVE WEEKS BE GRATEFUL
FOR THOSE TWELVE WEEKS AND COME
BACK. THERE WILL BE PEOPLE THAT
HAVE A GRANDMOTHER WHO WAS ILL-
LIKE MY GRANDDAUGHTER IS TAKING
HER AND HEARD AT MY DAUGHTER IS
TAKING HER HUSBAND'S
GRANDMOTHER BACK AND FORTH TO
LOS ANGELES AND SHE'S TAKING
TIME OFF BECAUSE HER EMPLOYER
ALLOWED HER THE TIME OFF NOT
BECAUSE THEY WERE MANDATED NOT
BECAUSE IT WAS THE LAW IT'S
BECAUSE EMPLOYERS REALLY CARE
ABOUT THEIR EMPLOYEES AND
MAKING SURE THAT THEY CAN TAKE
CARE OF THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS.
SO SHE'S TAKING CARE OF GOING
BACK FOR TO LA FOR CANCER
TREATMENTS AND SHE'S ALLOWED TO
TAKE THE TIME OFF AND OUR JOB
IS THERE WHEN SHE GETS BACK
SHE'S A NURSE SHE REALLY NEEDS
TO BE COMING BACK TO WORK TO
TAKE CARE OF THE SCHOOL WOULD
SITUATION. BUT GOING BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUE AT BIEBER ABOUT THE
WAY THAT BUSINESSES PUNITIVE
KIND AND THEN THE EXPRESSIONS
FOR LABOR THAT COME ALONG- THE
EXCEPTIONS FOR THIS BUILDING-
MY COLLEAGUES SAYS YOU KNOW WHY
AREN'T WAYS THIS BUILDING AND
WHAT. BRINGS IT IN SEVENTY
THINGS THIS THING DOESN'T THE
CELLS IN THE LABOR LAWS THAT
ARE PASSED IN THIS THING
BECAUSE THIS BUILDING. FOR
COMPLY. WITH WHAT ON. IN THE
REAL WORLD IN THE BUSINESS
WORLD. AND THAT'S EVIDENT. WHEN
THE SENATE PRO TEMPORE TOGETHER
WITH THE WORKPLACE CONDUCT
UNIT. IN HAD. A JUST A STRUGGLE
SHE WORKS SO HARD TO MAKE SURE
THAT WOMEN IN THIS BUILDING AND
PEOPLE IN THIS BUILDING HAD
OPPORTUNITY. TO HAVE A PLACE.
I'M TO GO TO IN THERE WOULD NOT
BE DISCRIMINATED AGAINST
RETALIATED AGAINST OR FIRED.
AND LONG BEFORE SHE WORKED HARD
TO MAKE THAT EQUAL WITH THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY. PEOPLE
WOULD JUST GET FIRED IN THIS
BUILDING FOR FILING A COMPLAINT
AGAINST THEIR LEGISLATOR
ALMIGHTY LEGISLATOR EMPLOYER.
FIRE OR REPLACED OR MOVE TO A
DIFFERENT OFFICE IN THE REAL
WORLD THAT WAS ILLEGAL AND NOW
THE SENATE PROTEIN JUST
RECENTLY IN THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS. HAS THANKS TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM AT LAKE ELSINORE
THE PAST A PIECE OF LEGISLATION
AFTER TRYING TO GET THROUGH
THIS BUILDING FOR FIVE YEARS.
THE SENATE PROTEIN WAS ABLE TO
PUT SOMETHING TOGETHER THAT
PROTECTED EMPLOYEES. SO THE
REASON WHY THIS BUILDING
DOESN'T OPERATE LIKE THE REST
OF US OPERATE IN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR IS COULD YOU WOULDN'T BE
ABLE TO FUNCTION. IT DOESN'T
WORK AND THAT'S EVIDENT FROM
WORKING HERE ON BOTH SIDES THAT
THE SENATE SIDE AND IS A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER. THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. CONSECUTIVE
LANGUAGE WOULD BE DETRIMENTAL
TO SMALL BUSINESSES I REALIZE
YOU WENT FROM ZERO TO FIVE
EMPLOYEES AND THERE'S A
PERCENAGE OF EMPLOYEES IT
WOULD BE SPARED FOR EMPLOYERS
THAT WOULD BE SPARED FROM THIS.
BUT THIS ALSO DOES NOT CREATE
CONSECUTIVE LANGUAGE SO A
PERSON. THAT CAN TAKE OFF AS A
TRUCK DRIVER. EVERY THURSDAY
AND FRIDAY FOR FIFTY TWO WEEKS
BECAUSE THEY DON'T EQUAL OUT
THAT THE WHOLE TIME FRAME RIGHT
THE FIFTY TWO WEEKS THE A
QUANTITY OF EIGHT HOURS.
BECAUSE IT'S NOT CONSECUTIVE.
HOW DOES MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BEAVER FIERY TRACK DRIVER IT
HAS TO BE. UNDER A DOT TEST HAS
TO HAVE A PERFORMANCE
EVALUATION HAS TO HAVE DOT
REQUIREMENTS IN DUTY
QUALIFICATIONS. TO FILL IN TWO
DAYS A WEEK. IT'S ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE. IF YOU LOOK AT LIKE
HE SAID WITH AB FIVE YOU KNOW
YOU HAVE OPTOMETRISTS GIVE
OPHTHALMOLOGIST YOU HAVE
INDIVIDUALS IF THEY TAKE TIME
OFF AND THEY CAN'T GET THEIR
EYES CHECKED. YOU HAVE ALL
THESE PEOPLE THAT ARE AFFECTED
AND THE LAWS THAT ARE PASSED
HERE. IN THIS IS JUST. ONE MORE
NAIL IN THE COFFIN I USED TO
SAY ITS DEATH BY A THOUSAND
PAPER CUTS BUT IT'S REALLY NOT
DEATH BY ITS DEATH BY STAB
WOUND NOW. I MEAN IT'S REALLY
BAD FOR BUSINESSES ESPECIALLY
OUT THERE WHEN THEY'RE BARELY
TRYING TO SURVIVE. THE GOVERNOR
JUST SHUT DOWN NINETEEN
COUNTIES IN RESTAURANTS WITHNO
DATA TO SHOW THAT IT'S
RESTAURANTS THAT'S CAUSING. THE
ISSUE THERE'S NO DOUBT AND
THERE'S NO THERE'S NOTHING THAT
SAYS CONTRACTORS YOUR SAY IT
GOES BACK TO. THIS RESTAURANT
SO THESE RESTAURANTS ARE SHUT
DOWN SOME OF THEM HAVE SMALL
FAMILY RESTAURANTS FIVE TEN
PEOPLE AND NOW THEY'RE BE
AFFECTED BY THIS. WE'RE NOW
THEY CAN'T THEY CAN'T EVEN
EMPLOYEES COME BACK TO WORK
AFTER PROTECT THAT JOB. FIND
SOMEBODY REPLACE THAT PERSONAL
GONE. DAYS A WEEK ONE DAY A
WEEK TWELVE CONCERT WEEKS.
BRING THOSE TWELVE COULD WEEKS.
THE EASIER TO FILL THAT
POSITION FOR TWELVE WEEKS AND
THEN LET THE PERSON GO. MANY
GUYS PROBABLY MAKE UP SOME
LOSSES KEEP LET SOMEBODY GO. IT
IT'S JUST ABSURD WHAT GUYS DO
TO THE PRIVATE. SECTOR I'M
ASKING YOU- JUST GIVE US A
BREAK. GIVE ALL THESE PEOPLE
THESE THOUSANDS HUNDREDS AND
THOUSANDS OF BUSINESSES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
OPPORTUNITY TO JUST GET BACK TO
NORMAL OR WHATEVER NORMAL IS
GONNA LOOK LIKE. AND THEN
PROVIDE PEOPLE A JOB AND NOT
HAVE TO DEAL WITH AGAIN ANOTHER
PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT IS
GOING TO HAMPER AND INHIBIT
THEIR ABILITY TO PROVIDE A
QUALITY PRODUCT TO CONTINUE TO
OPERATE THEIR BUSINESS I URGE
IN ABOUT. THANK YOU SENATOR
GROW SENATOR MITCHELL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ON MADAM
PRESIDENT. I FELT COMPELLED TO
STAND BECAUSE I THINK OUR
COLLEAGUES ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE AISLE FREQUENTLY SUGGESTS
THAT PERHAPS THEY ARE THE ONLY
ONES WHO HAD EXPERIENCE RUNNING
BUSINESS BEFORE WE BECAME
ELECTED THAT THEY HAVE A POINT
IN THE MARKET OF. OF WHAT IT'S
LIKE TO RUN A SMALL BUSINESS TO
BE AN EMPLOYER AND THAT'S JUST
NOT THE CASE LIKE MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES I RAN A BUSINESS
BEFORE I WAS ELECTED TO OFFICE.
NOW THE CHAMBER WILL HONORED AS
A JUST BECAUSE WITH THE
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION BUT I
MADE PAYROLL. I PAY PAYROLL
TAXES. I PROVIDED BENEFITS. I
HAD TO ABIDE BY ALL OF THE
LABOR LAWS THAT IMPACT ANY
BUSINESS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WHEN TIMES GOT
TOUGH I HAD TO MAKE THE
DECISION TO LAY OFF EMPLOYEES.
I HAD TO MAKE THE DECISION AT
ONE POINT TWO NO LONGER PROVIDE
HEALTH BENEFITS TO YOUR ENTIRE
FAMILY UNIT WE HAD TO MAKE THE
DECISION WE INCREASE THE POLICE
A SHARE OF THE PLAY BENEFITS. I
RAN A BUSINESS. I WAS VERY
PROUD IN RUNNING THE BUSINESS
NGUYEN. PAID FAMILY LEAVE CAME
INTO. OUR FRUITION THAT MY
FIRST EMPLOYEE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THAT WAS A MALE
EMPLOYEE. WHOSE Y. ARE
DELIVERED TWINS A BIT
PREMATURELY. AND I WAS PROUD OF
THE FACT THOSE YOUNG GIRLS WERE
NOW COLLEGE AGE- THAT THAT
THEIR FATHER WAS ABLE TO SPEND
TIME BONDING AT A VERY CRITICAL
PERIOD. IN THEIR DEVELOPMENT. I
WAS ALSO PROUD TO RUN A
BUSINESS THAT WAS RECOGNIZED IN
THOSE YOU KNOW RANKING SO. ON
THE BEST COMPANY EMPLOYER TO
WORK FOR. TO BE RECOGNIZED
MULTIPLE YEARS. AND WE WERE
RECOGNIZE NOT BECAUSE I WAS
PAYING TOP OF SCALE BASED ON
THE NATURE OF THE WORK WE WERE
COMPETING WITH GOVERNMENT QUITE
FRANKLY GOVERNMENT COULD PAY
BETTER HAD THEIR RETIREMENT
BENEFITS. BUT WE ALWAYS GOT THE
RANKING IS BEING A PREFERRED
EMPLOYER. BECAUSE OF THE KINDS
OF POLICIES THAT WE PUT IN
PLACE AS AN EMPLOYER. BECAUSE
WE WERE NOT GOING TO CREATE
THIS BIG DIVIDE BETWEEN THE
HAVES AND THE HAVE NOTS THAT
YOU OFTEN HEAR IN THESE
DISCUSSIONS BETWEEN EMPLOYERS
AND THE PEOPLE WHO. HELP THEIR
BUSINESSES FUNCTION BY BEING
THEIR EMPLOYEES. WE WANTED TO
CREATE A CULTURE IN WHICH
PEOPLE WANTED TO COME TO WORK
AND GIVE THEIR BEST EFFORT TO
HELP US DELIVER THE BEST
PRODUCT POSSIBLE BY BEING
CONSCIOUS OF THEIR LIVES AND SO
WE WERE PROUD TO BE ABLE TO
PUT. OUR POLICY IN PLACE AROUND
FAMILY LEAVE WE WERE PROUD TO
SUPPORT EMPLOYEES WHO WERE SICK
BY ALLOWING OTHER EMPLOYEES TO
DONATE TIME WE WERE PROUD TO DO
THAT AND IT SHOWED IN TERMS OF
THE WORK PRODUCT. THE LOW
TURNOVER. OF MY EMPLOYEES. AND
SO WHAT HAVE THOSE EXPERIENCES
TO. I THINK IT'S WONDERFUL THAT
SOME OF US HAVE HAD GREAT
INDIVIDUAL EXPERIENCES WITH
EMPLOYERS WHO LOVE US. ALLOW US
TO TAKE TIME TO TAKE CARE OF
OUR CHILDREN AND OUR
GRANDPARENTS THAT'S WONDERFUL.
THAT'S OUR INDIVIDUAL LIFE
EXPERIENCE. AND SO WE'RE
LOOKING AT. HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS WHO WORK FOR
COMPANIES WHO DON'T HAVE THOSE
POLICIES AND DON'T HAVE THOSE
PROTECTIONS THAT'S THE POINT OF
A LOT MAKING. WELL THEN I WOULD
SAY I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT WE
DIFFERENTIATE. UNDER THE LAW
SALARIED EMPLOYEES AND THE WORK
EXPECTATION OF A SALARIED
EMPLOYEE VERSUS AN HOURLY
EMPLOYEE IT'S NOT. OKAY TO
STAND ON THE FLOOR AND MAKE
ASSERTIONS AND JUST MAKE THE
STATEMENTS BECAUSE YOU DON'T
SUPPORT A BILL THAT MAY NOT BE
ACCURATE. ARE SALARIED
EMPLOYEES ARE EXPECTED TO DO
THE JOB UNTIL THE JOB IS DONE
HOURLY EMPLOYEES YOU ALL ARE
WELL AWARE THERE'S A DIFFERENT
LEGAL EXPECTATION. AND I'M SURE
THAT THIS HOUSE AND ALL OF US
IS EMPLOYER HONOR THAT- I AM
PROUD TO STAND UP AND SUPPORT
SB ONE THREE EIGHT THREE
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S IN THE
BEST INTEREST OF OUR OVERALL.
EMPLOYER EMPLOYEE ENVIRONMENT.
IT'S TRAGIC THAT IN THIS
COUNTRY OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN FRANCISCO IDENTIFIED THAT
WE CONTINUE TO WHEN WE HAVE
THESE CONVERSATIONS WHEN WE
LOOK AT THIS LIST. LOCAL
ORGANIZATIONS THAT DO LOBBY ON
BEHALF OF BUSINESS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THAT WE CONTINUE
TO HAVE THIS CONVERSATION THE
CONTEXT OF HAVE VERSUS HAVE
NOTS US VERSUS THEM. IF
BUSINESS IS IN PROTECTED AND
THE AND THE WHOLE ECONOMY WILL
TANK I COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND WE
HAVE TO CREATE A SENSE OF
BALANCE. BUT GOVERNMENT HAD TO
INTERVENE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE WAS AN EIGHT HOUR DAY AND
A FORTY HOUR WORK WEEK THAT
CHILD LABOR LAWS WERE CREATED
THAT WE AGAIN CREATED
PROTECTIONS FOR SALARY VERSUS
HOURLY EMPLOYEES. THAT WORK
PLACES HAVE TO BE INTEGRATED.
THAT WOMEN COULD ALSO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK OUTSIDE OF
THE HOME IF YOU WILL AND SO
THERE HAS BEEN A CONSTRUCTIVE
IMPORTANT HEALTH THE ROLE THAT
GOVERNMENT IS PLAY. IN MAKING
SURE THE BUSINESS IN THIS
COUNTRY DOESN'T VIOLATE THE
BASIC HUMAN RIGHTS OF THE
PEOPLE THEY EMPLOY FOR ALL
THOSE REASONS I WILL CONTINUE
SUPPORT THIS CONCEPT ABOUT HOW
WE CREATE A SOCIETY IN WHICH-
FAMILY IS SUPPORTED. AND PEOPLE
AREN'T FORCED TO MAKE A CHOICE.
MANY OF HIS HERE ON THE FLOOR
I'VE BEEN HERE LONG ENOUGH NOW
THAT I LOST APPEARANCE INSERTED
IN THE SENATE. I MADE THE
CHOICE TO MISS ONE DAY ON THIS
FOR WHEN MY MOTHER DIED. THE
CHOICE I MADE. BUT PEOPLE
SHOULD BE FORCED BASED ON THEIR
EMPLOYMENT STATUS TO DECIDE
WHAT ROLE THEY'RE GOING PLAY IN
SUPPORTING THEIR FAMILIES IN
THE RIGHT IN GREATEST NEED
CALIFORNIA IS THE STATE THAT
CHAMPION ALL OF THE RESEARCH
AND ZERO TO FIVE BRING
DEVELOPMENT. FOR WE CLAIM WE
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
BONDING WITH CHILDREN. WE CLAIM
WE UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
SCHOOL READINESS WE CLAIM WE
CARE ABOUT CHILDREN AND HAVE
FAMILY VALUES. THIS IS A
PERFECT EXAMPLE OF EXHIBITING
AND OPERATIONALIZE IN YOUR
BELIEF IN CORE FAMILY VALUES
WHICH IS WHAT I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THE TODAY. THANK YOU
SENATOR MITCHELL CENTER GLAZER.
CORD. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
TO. AND NUMBERS. WE CAN WE CAN
TOGETHER THIS MORNING AT A VERY
SAD TIME. OUR STATE FOR OUR
WORLD. MORE THAN TEN MILLION
PEOPLE AROUND THE WORLD HAVE
BEEN INFECTED BY THE CORONA
VIRUS. NUMBER FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE HAVE DIED. JUST
YESTERDAY IN THE UNITED STATES.
FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE WERE
NOTIFIED THAT THEY HAD BEEN
INFECTED. JUST YESTERDAY. AND
HEY HERE IN OUR STATE. JUST THE
FIRST THREE DAYS OF THIS WEEK.
TWENTY THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
WE'RE TOLD THAT THEY HAVE THAT
CODE NINETEEN VIRUS. AT A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY PLUS. OF OUR
CALIFORNIA FAMILY DIED THIS
WEEK JUST SO FAR. IF YOU SAID
TO ME THAT THE LEGISLATION
BEFORE US. I WAS GOING TO A
GOING TO AFFECT THOSE WHO WERE
FACING THIS TERRIBLE HAND DOWN
AT. I WOULD BE THE FIRST TO SAY
I WANT TO VOTE FOR THAT BILL.
YOU KNOW. THE GOVERNOR'S ORDER
ON MARCH SIXTEENTH SAID THAT IF
YOU'RE- SIXTY FIVE YEARS OUR
OLDER OR YOU HAVE AN UNDERLYING
MEDICAL CONDITION. THAT YOU
MUST SHELTER IN PLACE. PERIOD
THAT ORDER REMAINS IN EFFECT
THE EXCEPTION WAS THAT IF YOU
HAD TO UNDERTAKEN ESSENTIAL
ACTIVITY. TO GET FOOD OR
MEDICINE. FOR US AS SENATORS
THAT ESSENTIAL ACTIVITY IS
BEING HERE ON THE FLOOR AT THIS
MOMENT IN TIME DESPITE THE
RISKS TO ALL OF US AND NOT JUST
THOSE WHO ARE. PARK PARK.
REPRESENT THAT GROUP OF PEOPLE
THAT ARE VULNERABLE BUT YOUR
FAMILY'S ANYONE WHO YOU'RE
LIVING WITH. AND SO. ONE OF THE
KEY QUESTIONS THIS MORNING FOR
ME. IS THIS BILL AN ESSENTIAL
BILL. IS THIS JUSTIFY OUR
PRESENCE HERE ON THE FLOOR. IT
JUSTIFIES THAT ESSENTIAL
ACTIVITY FOR US THE SENATORS.
NOW DURING MANY FLOOR DEBATE
HERE INSIDE AND ALSO OUTSIDE
THESE CHAMBERS. WE HEAR. I
DESIRE TO GO AFTER THAT. THE
TITANS ON WALL STREET. THE
BIGGEST COMPANIES IN THE WORLD
IN THEIR PROFITS. WE NEED TO
CREATE A BALANCE AND FAIRNESS
IN OUR WORLD. BUT MEMBERS DOES
THE BILL BEFORE US TODAY DO
THAT. IS IT TARGET THOSE BIG
WEALTHY COMPANIES IN OUR WORLD
THE TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF THEIR
EMPLOYEES. I THINK WE ALL KNOW
THE ANSWER IS NOW. IT DOESN'T
DO THAT. THIS BILL IS TARGETED
TOWARDS THE SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER. A SMALL SHOPKEEPER THE
SMALL RESTAURANT OWNER.THAT
TARGETED TOWARDS THE BIG
WEALTHY COMPANIES IN OUR WORLD.
I HAVE HEARD. SOME OF THE
DEBATE THIS MORNING. A
SUGGESTION THAT THIS
LEGISLATION AND ITS ECONOMIC
IMPACT HAS BEEN STUDY.
THOROUGHLY THOUGHTFULLY IN
DEATH. AND I WOULD CHALLENGE
THAT ASSERTION. WHEN HAVE WE
EVER EXPERIENCED A PANDEMIC
THAT WE'RE EXPERIENCING TODAY
WHAT HAVE WE EVER EXPERIENCED A
TIME IN WHICH TENS OF THOUSANDS
IF NOT HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA. ARE
CLOSED AT THIS MOMENT. WITH
FEARS THAT THEY MAY NEVER. OPEN
AGAIN. SENATE BILL. IN THE
QUIET AT THIS MOMENT. I HEAR.
THAT SHOPKEEPER AT HOME. CRYING.
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT ARE
THEY GOING TO DO. WITH THE
SITUATION WHICH THEY FIND
THEMSELVES AT. ALL THAT HARD
WORK. ALL THAT SAVINGS. ALL.
THE COURAGE THAT IT TOOK TO THE
OPEN UP THAT SHOT. AND NOW WHAT
ARE THEY GOING. TO DO. AND WHAT
IS GOING TO BE THE IMPACT. ON
THEIR FAMILY. ON THEIR CHILDREN.
WHAT ARE THE CHOICES THAT THEY
MAY FACE. LOSING HEALTHCARE
LOSING EVERYTHING ALL THEIR
DREAMS. LOS. AND WHAT OF THEIR
WORKERS. WHETHER IT'S FIVE OR
FIFTEEN. WHAT AT ONE OF THEIR
LIVES NOW AFFECTED. AND WHAT
CAN WE DO ABOUT THEIR
CIRCUMSTANCE. WHEN THEY LOSE
THEIR JOB. THERE'S NO
HEALTHCARE THERE'S NOTHING
THERE'S NO PAYCHECK THERE'S
NOTHING. SO WITH A QUIET AT
THIS MOMENT I THINK ABOUT THAT
SHOPKEEPER. AND THEIR MUFFLED
CRIES IN THE BACK ROOM BECAUSE
THEY DON'T WANT THEIR FAMILY TO
KNOW THE SORROW THAT THEY'RE
GOING THROUGH. AND WHO ARE THE
SHOPKEEPERS. THERE IMMIGRANTS
THE REFUGEES. THERE PEOPLE OF
COLOR THEY'RE PEOPLE WHO MAYBE
DIDN'T EVEN GRADUATE FROM HIGH
SCHOOL BUT THEY'VE SCRAP
TOGETHER THE MONEY TO TRY TO
CREATE AN ENTERPRISE TO TRY TO
MAKE A BETTER LIFE FOR THEM AND
THEIR FAMILIES. SO ARE WE HEAR
ON THE SENATE FLOOR. DEBATING A
MEASURE THAT WILL HOUSE THE
HOMELESS. FEED THE HUNGRY.
PROVIDE RELIEF FOR THOSE WHO
HAVE LOST A JOB. IS THAT THE
ESSENTIAL WORK IN WHICH WE'VE
COME TOGETHER THIS MORNING THE
DEBATE. I THINK THE ANSWER IS.
THAT DOES NOT MATCH THE
LEGISLATION THAT'S BEFORE US. I
THINK ONE OF THE HARDEST JOBS
FOR A SENATOR. IS WHEN ONE GETS
A MEASURE THAT IS COMES FROM
THE BIGGEST HEART. THE MOST A
PLACE OF THE GREATEST
COMPASSION. THAT WE KNOW HAS
THE BEST OF INTENTIONS TO MAKE
OUR WORLD AND MAKE EACH OF OUR
LIVES BETTER. WHEN WE WHEN THAT
LEGISLATION COMES IN FRONT OF
US AND YET THE CIRCUMSTANCES OR
THE BUDGET. JUST DOESN'T. MAKE
THAT MOMENT WHERE YOU HAVE TO
SAY YES I'D LIKE TO DO THAT BUT-
IT'S THE HARDEST THING TO SAY
NO. NOT TODAY. NOT RIGHT NOW.
I'M GONNA LEAVE IT TO OTHERS TO
TALK ABOUT. THE PRIVATE RIGHT
OF ACTION IN THIS LEGISLATION
AND THE CONSEQUENCES THAT MIGHT
MAKE. I'M GONNA LEAVE ASIDE THE
ISSUE OF THE FACT THAT THIS IS
A BUDGET TRAILER BILL. THE
WARPING OF THE PROCESS. CREATES
PRESSURES I EACH OF YOU THAT
WOULDN'T BE THERE THIS WAS A
NORMAL PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THAT GONE THROUGH THE PROCESS
IN THE PROPER WAY. I KNOW I
KNOW THAT THIS BILL WILL PASS
TODAY I KNOW THAT. I GET IT.
BUT IT SHOULDN'T BE THE WAY
THAT WE DO OUR BEST TO WORK IN
THE CIRCUMSTANCES IN WHICH WE
FIND OURSELVES IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE PANDEMIC. WITH CONSEQUENCES
THAT ARE STILL COMPLETELY
UNIMAGINABLE. THE PROPONENTS
HAVE A BIG HEART. THEY'RE
TRYING TO DO THE RIGHT THING.
AND A DIFFERENT MOMENTS IT
MIGHT BE SOMETHING THAT SHOULD
BE ADVANCED. ALTHOUGH I KNOW
IT'LL BE ADVANCE HERE TODAY.
BUT IN THIS QUIET MOMENTS I DO
HERE. SIGN OF THAT SHOPKEEPER.
AND I THINK THIS IS NOT THE
TIME TO PUT. ADDITIONAL
OBLIGATIONS ON DOWN WITHOUT
FULL STUDY AND REVIEW. AND WITH
THAT I UNFORTUNATELY WILL BE
CASTING A NO VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER GLAZER CENTER MELINDA'S
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. WHEN
I FIRST GOT TO LEGISLATURE- THE
MANTRA WAS GENERALLY THAT BIG
BUSINESS WAS THE ENEMY THAT WE
HAD TO GO AFTER THERE'S
CORPORATE GREEDY- GIANTS WHO
WERE NOT DOING RIGHT BY THEIR
EMPLOYEES AND IT SEEMS AS
THOUGH NOW WE HAVE TAKEN
APOLOGIZE IN GOING AFTER THE
BIG BUSINESSES THAT EMPLOY
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA AND NOW WE'RE GOING
TO GO AFTER THE SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER. SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
ARE NOT. EVIL THEY CARE ABOUT
THEIR EMPLOYEES. I. I DO I HAVE
TO PAUSE FOR A MOMENT AND BANK-
THE GOOD SENATORS FROM LOS
ANGELES AND SANTA BARBARA IN
BERKELEY FOR ACTUALLY MAKING
THE POINT TODAY AND THEIR
COMMENTS ABOUT THEIR OWN
PERSONAL EXPERIENCES ABOUT WHY
THIS BILL ISN'T NECESSARY.
BECAUSE THEY TALKED ABOUT HOW
THEIR EMPLOYER. ALLOW THEM THE
TIME OFF WHEN THEY NEEDED IT OR
THAT THEY ALLOW THEIR EMPLOYEES
THE TIME OFF WHEN THEY NEEDED
IT WITHOUT THE BIG HAND OF
GOVERNMENT COMING DOWN AND
SMACKING THEM AND SAYING THAT
THEY HAD TO DO IT. THIS IS WHAT
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS DO
BECAUSE THEY VALUE THEIR
EMPLOYEES THEY WANT TO KEEP
THEM IT IS MORE EXPENSIVE TO
TRAIN SOMEONE NEW AND MOST
TIMES YOU DON'T WANT TO BECAUSE
YOU REALLY DO BECOME. LIKE A
FAMILY. BUT I CANNOT IMAGINE
WHAT IT'S LIKE TO HAVE FIVE
EMPLOYEES. AND. HAVE THAT
PERSON LEAVE FOR AN EXTENDED
PERIOD OF TIME IN TRYING TO
FIND SOMEONE ELSE TO REPLACE
THEM WHETHER IT'S CONSECUTIVE
DAYS ARE NOT WHICH I THINK IS A
VERY INTERESTING POINT I HOPE
THE AUTHOR- ADDRESSES IN HER
CLOTHES AS PROMISED. THIS
CORONA VIRUS HAS DECIMATED YOU
KNOW UR ECONOMY EVERYBODY
KNOWS THAT IN HERE AND I DON'T
KNOW WHEN IT'S GOING TO COME
BACK NONE OF US DO. BUT I DO
KNOW WHEN EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM
KNOWS THAT THE SMALL BUSINESSES
ARE THE ONES WHO ARE HURTING
THE MOST. IF ANYBODY WATCH THE
NEWS LAST NIGHT THE LOCAL NEWS.
THEY WERE INTERVIEWING THE
OWNER OF SU ON TRIPS RIGHT HERE
IN SACRAMENTO HE'S NOW YOU KNOW
HE'S- CLEANING TABLES HE'S
DOING THE SHOPPING HE'S DOING
THE COOKING HE'S DOING
EVERYTHING JUST TO TRY TO STAY
OPEN AND NOT LOSE THE BUSINESS.
AND THAT IS GOING TO CONTINUE
FORWARD. I DON'T KNOW YOU KNOW
HOW LONG. BUT TO PUT A POLICY
LIKE THIS IN PLACE AT A TIME
WHEN BUSINESS OWNERS AREN'T
EVEN SURE IF THEY'RE GOING TO
MAKE IT I THINK IS INCREDIBLY
IRRESPONSIBLE. AND I DON'T
THINK IT'S FAIR TO THE
EMPLOYEES AND I CERTAINLY DON'T
EMPLOYERS. SO I WOULD URGE YOU
TO PIES AT THIS MOMENT REALLY
THINK. ABOUT THE EFFECT THIS IS
GOING TO HAVE. ON THOSE SMALLER
BUSINESSES BECAUSE- POLICIES
LIKE THIS ARE WHAT RIVE THEM
OUT OF CALIFORNIA OR CAUSE THEM
TO CLOSE COMPLETELY NEVER TO
RETURN SO I WOULD URGE AN EVENT
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THANK
YOU CENTER MELINDA'S CENTER
MORE LAW. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT OF. BEING PART OF
IMMIGRANT FAMILY WE IMMIGRATED
TO THE ORANGE COUNTY OF MY DAD
HAD TO START OVER HE HAD A- ED
NO REASON TO LEAVE THE
NETHERLANDS BUT- IF I'M SELF
GOING INTO SALES. SPUR SELLING
INSURANCE AND SO INSURANCE. YOU
KNOW THERE ARE DAYS- WHEN YOU
HAVE A GOOD GOOD WEEKS AND IN
YOUR TIMES WERE YOU HAVE- DRY
SPELLS BUT HE WOULD CERTAINLY
WORK VERY LONG HOURS AND SO.
THERE ARE TIMES THE CHILD THAT
WOULD GO TO MY MOTHER AND ASK
FOR SOMETHING. MY MOTHER WHO
WHO TURNS NINETY THIS MONTH-
I'D ASK- IN THE STORE AT HOME
HE CAN CAN YOU BUY ME THIS. AND
SHE WOULD JUST. TURNED TO ME
AND SAY SON. IF I HAD A MILLION
DOLLARS I GIVE IT TO YOU. IT
WAS ONE OF HER PARENTS TAPES I
WOULD HEAR IT OVER AND OVER AND
OVER PARENT CAPE SIR WHEN YOU.
HEAR YOUR PARENTS SAY THE SAME
THING LIKE YOU KNOW JIMMY'S
GONNA JUMP OFF THE BRIDGE THAT
DOESN'T MEAN YOU HAVE TO JUMP
OFF THE BRIDGE AND DOLLARS.
INTERESTING PHRASES BUT IT WAS
HER WAY OF SAYING SON. WE'D WE
CAN'T AFFORD IT. RIGHT NOW. AND
I UNDERSTOOD THAT AND IT'S ALL
SHE HAD TO SAY. SON OF I HAD A
MILLION DOLLARS TO GIVE IT TO
YOU AND THAT WAS THE END OF OUR
DISCUSSION I WOULDN'T NAGGAR
**** ANY. ANYMORE SO AS A
FORMER BUSINESS OWNER I
APPRECIATE FAMILY LEAVE. AS A
GRANDFATHER I APPRECIATETHEM
RELIEF I HAVE FRIENDS WITH
WORKING SPOUSES AND- MY
DAUGHTER IN LAW'S ENJOYING.
FAMILY LEAVE AS WE SPEAK AND I
WAS INFORMED THIS WEEKEND THAT
MY OTHER SON OF WILL BE
ENJOYING FAMILY LEAVE AND
FEBRUARY OF NEXT YEAR SO. I
UNDERSTAND. SB THIRTY THREE IS
A STRETCH GOAL. BUT THERE'S THE
FLIP SIDE. AND THAT IS THE
BENEFIT. BUT WE HAVE TO LOOK AT
IT'S A LITTLE HARDER AS AS MANY
OF SAID ON THE ON THE FLOOR IT
REQUIRES A TEMPORARY
REPLACEMENT OF THE NECESSARY
POSITION AND NOW MAY BE UP TO
TWELVE WEEKS WITH JOB
PROTECTION. THAT'S THAT'S
ADMIRABLE THAT'S UNDERSTANDABLE
BUT IT'S A STRETCH GOAL IT
TAKES IT A LITTLE FARTHER WE'VE
BEEN DOING FAMILY LEAVE BUT NOW
WE'RE TAKING A LITTLE FURTHER
WITH SOME PRETTY SERIOUS.
PARAMETERS AND AS HAS BEEN
STATED WE'RE IN A UNIQUE
ECONOMIC FREE FALL WHERE MANY
BUSINESSES HAVE HAD THEIR
RESERVES DEPLETED. AND MANY
MORE HAVE HEADED TO BANKRUPTCY
COURTS. AND THERE ARE PLENTY OF
STATES THAT WOULD LOVE TO HAVE
OUR BUSINESSES. FOR COLLEAGUES
THIS BILL IS POOR TIMING.
BUSINESSES NEEDRELIEF NOT MORE
COSTS RESULTING FROM STEPPING
SHORTAGE EXTENSIONS OR
POTENTIALLY RETAIN AN ATTORNEY
BECAUSE THE STATUS SHOWED UP AT
THEIR FRONT DOOR THE DEAL WITH
AN ALLEGED VIOLATION. SO I
FULLY UNDERSTAND. WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO. BUT LET'S WAIT ON
SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE I URGE
A NO VOTE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU CENTER
MORLOCK CENTER GALGIANI. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF MY
QUESTION IS TO THE AUTHOR OF
THE AUTHOR WOULD TAKE A
QUESTION PLEASE. SENATOR
JACKSON'S. TO DO SO AND-
ANSWERED MY CLOTHES THANK YOU-
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW ABOUT THE
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION. MY
CONCERN IS THAT- AS A MEMBER
I'VE BEEN HERE FOR DISCUSSIONS
ON FAMILY LEAVE IN THE PAST
THAT WHEN THIS BILL CAME UP AND
IT WASN'T YET IMPRINT. EVEN I
DIDN'T UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
DIFFERENT LEAVES WERE THE
AMOUNT OF TIME WHETHER THEY
WERE PAID AND PAID- AND HAD TO.
TRY TO DO SOME RESEARCH WE HAD
A DISCUSSION ABOUT IT. IF I
DIDN'T REMEMBER IT I HAVE
CONCERNS THAT AN EMPLOYER
ESPECIALLY IN EMPLOYER WITHOUT
LEGAL COUNSEL AND AN EMPLOYER
WHO IS NOT A MEMBER. OF THE
CHAMBER FOR EXAMPLE. HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO KEEP TRACK OF
THIS BECAUSEI'M SURE THAT WITH
THE FINANCIAL SITUATION THAT
WE'RE IN THAT THERE WON'T BE
NOTIFICATIONS. SENT TO
BUSINESSES FULL OF A BUSINESS
OWNER MAKES A MISTAKE AND TELLS
AN EMPLOYEE INITIALLY. THAT I
CAN'T AFFORD TO ALLOW YOU TO
TAKE THE TIME OFF. IS YOUR
OPPORTUNITY TO CARE FOR THAT
BUSINESS OWNER. IF INDEED THEY
LEARNED THAT I'M WRONG THE LAW
SAYS THIS I'M REQUIRED TO GIVE
THAT EMPLOYEE LEAVE. IS THAT
EMPLOYERS STILL SUBJECT TO A
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION THAT'S
MY QUESTION. THANK YOU. THE
CENTER GALGIANI THINK. IT'S AN
ADDRESSING THAT IN YOUR CLOTHES
SENATOR TO RAZA. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. I AM- I RISE IN IT
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. AND I
SO APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
AUTHOR- I HAVEN'T BEEN HERE ALL
THOSE YEARS BUT- FROM THE
STORIES I CAN TELL SHE HAS
PERSEVERED AND JUST STUCK WITH
IT. AND I AM VERY PROUD TO BE
HERE AT THIS PARTICULAR MOMENT-
I TRY TO LOOK AT THINGS THROUGH
THE LENS OF WHAT'S FOR THE
GREATER GOOD. OF BECAUSE THE
ALWAYS BE SOME. CONFLICT OF
THIS OPINION OVER THAT OPINION
BUT WHAT'S FOR THE GREATER GOOD.
THIS BILL IS GOING TO ENSURE
THAT MILLIONS. OF CALIFORNIANS.
WHO PAY INTO PAID FAMILY LEAVE
AND OTHER BENEFITS THAT THEY DO
SO WITHOUT RISKING THEIR JOBS.
THAT'S THE FUNDAMENTAL THING
WITHOUT RISKING THEIR JOBS IN
RIGHT NOW THERE ARE MILLIONS.
WHO CAN BE FIRED FOR TAKING
TIME OFF IS BASED ON THE
EMPLOYER SIZE. SO WHETHER YOU
HAVE FIVE COWORKERS ARE FIVE
HUNDRED YOUR CHILDREN AND ILL
LOVED ONES NEED TO JUST THE
SAME. NO ONE SHOULD BE FIRED
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A CHILD OR
GET CANCER OR NEED TO BE WITH
THE DYING PARENT. AS A LATINA
WOMAN WHO'S WORKED WITH LOW
WAGE WORKERS MOST OF MY ADULT
LIFE. TO SEE THAT LOW WAGE
WORKERS WHO ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY PEOPLE OF
COLOR. AND ARE MORE LIKELY TO
WORK FOR SMALL EMPLOYERS
THEREFORE CURRENTLY LACK JOB
PROTECTION. MOST WORKERS PAY
IN. OF AN OUT OF EVERY SINGLE
CHECK BUT LOW WAGE WORKERS ARE
LESS LIKELY TO USE IT THAN
HIGHER WAGE WORKERS. AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WORKERS WHO ARE LESS
THAN TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
MADE UP. ALMOST 40% OF THE
WORKFORCE YET THEY ONLY
REPRESENTED A LITTLE OVER 20%
OF THE CLAIMS HIGHER EARNERS
HAD HIGHER UTILIZATION RATES
THIS MEANS THAT PEOPLE EARNING
LOW WAGES ARE SUBSIDIZING
HIGHER PAID WORKERS. PEOPLE
EARNING LOW WAGE WORKERS ARE
LESS LIKELY TO BE AWARE BUT A
TOP REASON THAT DAY REPORT FOR
NOT USING IT IS FEAR OF LOSING
THEIR JOB FEAR OF LOSING THEIR
JOB. CALIFORNIA LED THE NATION
IN IMPLEMENTING- PAID FAMILY
LEAVE SIXTEEN YEARS AGO BUT
WE'VE NOW FALLEN BEHIND. WERE
OTHER STATES MASSACHUSETTS NEW
YORK CONNECTICUT AND OTHERS
HAVE GOTTEN AHEAD OF US. IT IS
TIME TO UPDATE OUR LAW. SO THAT
WE'RE NOT DISCUSSING THIS FOR
THE FIRST TIME WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT UPDATING IT SO THAT HARD
WORKING MEN AND WOMEN CAN BE
THERE FOR THEIR FAMILIES
WITHOUT RISKING THEIR JOBS.
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS ARE ASKING FOR
THIS PROTECTION. I BET IF
EVERYONE TOOK A POLL IN YOUR
DISTRICT AND ASKED. ASK YOUR
RESIDENTS ASK YOUR YOUR- VOTERS
IN THOSE AREAS. F. IF THEY
THOUGHT IT WAS FAIR FOR SOMEONE
TO GET FIRED AFTER TAKING A
LEAVE LIKE THIS I BET EVERY BUT
MAJORITY WOULD SAY NO IT'S NOT
FAIR WE DO SUPPORT A LAW THAT
GAVE PEOPLE THE RIGHT TO GO
BACK TO THEIR JOBS YES. I BET
YOU THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY
WOULD SAY YES. SO THE EMPLOYERS
TO DO RIGHT RIGHT NOW BY THEIR
EMPLOYEES. GREAT I'M REALLY
GLAD TO SEE THAT I KNOW THAT
THEY EXIST I KNOW THAT THERE
ARE MANY WHO DO IT. THEY'VE GOT
NOTHING TO LOSE. BUT THOSE WHO
DON'T DO RIGHT. I'LL HAVE TO
LEARN TO DO RIGHT BY THEIR
EMPLOYEES. IF NOT NOW WHEN IS
ALWAYS AN EXCUSE. COLLEAGUES I
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
SENATOR AS A GOOD MORNING
CENTER LEYVA THE FLOORS OR-
THANK YOU MISTER FOR A
PRESIDENT FOR ALLOWING ME TO
USE YOUR DESK GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS. AS A PROUD CO AUTHOR
OF THIS BILL AND THE CHAIR OF
THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
I RISE IN STRONG BUT
DISAPPOINTED SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
EXPANDS ACCESS TO PAID FAMILY
LEAVE BY PROVIDING JOB
PROTECTION TO VAST MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYEES WOMEN
ESPECIALLY. FAMILY LEAVE AS
LONG BEEN A PRIORITY FOR THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS BECAUSE WE
RECOGNIZE THAT FAMILY LEAVE
THAT IS JOB PROTECTED AND
ADEQUATELY PAID IS ESSENTIAL
FOR WOMEN'S EQUALITY AND
SUCCESS IN THE WORKFORCE. WITH
MORE WOMEN IN THE WORK FORCE
THAN EVER BEFORE WE CAN NO
LONGER TAKE FOR GRANTED THE
WORK OF CARE GIVING THAT WOMEN
LONG PERFORMED WITHOUT
RECOGNITION OR PAY. WE MUST
MAKE SPACE FOR CARE GIVING AS
PART OF THE WORK ENVIRONMENT.
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT WHEN THESE
IMPORTANT ADJUSTMENTS ARE MADE.
CHOOSE THE LIVES OF WOMEN IN
PRIZE IMPROVE THE LIVES OF THE
ENTIRE FAMILY. JOB PROTECTED
THE FAMILY LEAVE INCREASES
WOMEN'S PARTICIPATION IN THE
LABOR FORCE I MAKES NEW MOTHERS
MORE LIKELY TO RETURN AFTER
CHILDBIRTH WHICH I THINK THAT
SOMETIMES WE TAKE FOR GRANTED
WE ACT LIKE GROWING A HUMAN
FRIEND INSIDE OF YOU AND THEN
BIRTHING THEM IS NOT THAT
DIFFICULT. SO THE WOMEN WHO ARE
WOMEN THE ONLY WITH ALL WOMEN
ARE THE ONLY ONES WHO CAN HAVE
A CHILD. THEIR BODIES NEED TO
RECUPERATE AFTER THAT AND THE
SENATOR FROM OAKLAND I AM
SHOCKED THAT YOU HAVE TO COME
BACK TO WORK AFTER TWO WEEKS OF
THAT JUST SEEMS UNCONSCIONABLE.
WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT STRONG
INEQUITABLE FAMILY LEAVE
POLICIES ENCOURAGE FATHERS TO
TAKE LEAVE AS WELL. RESULTING
IN MORE EQUITABLE SHARING OF
CAREGIVING RESPONSIBILITIES.
WHEN IS ABSENT. LIMóN LIKELY
END UP LEAVING THE WORKFORCE
ALTOGETHER. SOME TO RETURN
YEARS LATER AND THE END RESULT
IS A WIDENING AND THE PAY GAP
LOSS OF EARNING POTENTIAL. LARA
RETIREMENT BENEFITS THIS BILL
CRITICAL FOR ALL. BUT CLEARLY
MAKES INCREDIBLE STRIDES AND
HELPING TO UPLIFT WOMEN.
HOWEVER I WOULD BE REMISS IF I
DID NOT MENTION THAT I AM
DEEPLY DISAPPOINTED BY SOME OF
MY DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUES. AND
WHILE THIS BILL WILL HAVE GREAT
IMPACT THEIR SHIP MORE WORK TO
BE DONE. EVERY YEAR EVEN HERE
TWENTY TWENTY. THE REALITY IS
THAT THERE WILL BE SOME WOMEN
WHO GIVE BIRTH AND WILL NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO JOE ACCESS TO
JOB PROTECTED PREGNANCY
DISABILITY LEAVE. AS WAS STATED
BY THE AUTHOR YOU PAY IN YOU
SHOULD BE ABLE TO USE IT.
CALIFORNIA CAN AND MUST DO
BETTER. I TO HEAR PEOPLE
CRYING. I HEAR WOMEN CRYING
WOMEN WHO GIVE BIRTH AND HAVE
TO LEAVE THEIR CHILD TOO SOON
TO GO BACK TO WORK BECAUSE THEY
HAVE TO PROVIDE FOR THAT CHILD.
MEMBERS WE HAVE MISSED A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPAND THIS TO
ALL WOMEN. THIS BILL IN ITS
ORIGINAL FORM WAS A STATEMENT
OF OUR VALUES OF WHAT WE VALUE
WHAT DO WE VALUE DO WE VALUE
FAMILY. DO WE VALUE PEOPLE WHO
GIVE BIRTH TO CHILDREN DO WE
VALUE THAT. NO WE VALUE STATUS
WE VALUE STUFF AND WE VALUE
MONEY. WELL THE FOOD VALUE
PEOPLE HEALTH CARE AND
COMMUNITY WHAT WHAT OUR WORLD
LOOK LIKE THEN. AS I STATED IN
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE HEARING
THIS IS NOT ABOUT A LACK OF HOW
TO THIS IS ABOUT A LACK OF WILL
TO. I TOO HAVE A DREAM LIKE
MARTIN LUTHER KING DID. I HAVE
A DREAM THAT SOME DAY ALL
DEMOCRATS WILL SUPPORT WOMEN. I
URGE AN AYE VOTE. BUT IT'S IN
GERMAN THE SENATE WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GO TO CENTER HER TARA.
CENTER TITLE WE'RE GONNA HAVE
YOU COME UP TO THE PODIUM HERE
IN THE MIDDLE THE ROOM PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES WE CANNOT DENY THAT
THERE IS AN AND JUSTICE WHEN IT
COMES TO WHO CAN AND CANNOT
TAKE PROTECTIVELY. THERE'S NO
DOUBT IN MY MIND ABOUT THAT.
FOR THIS REASON I HAVE MADE
EVERY EFFORT TO SUPPORT THIS
LEGISLATION AND MAKE SURE IN
THE PROCESS WE DON'T CREATE
ANOTHER AND JUSTICE. FOR
PEOPLE. OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF
DAYS I HAVE SPENT NUMEROUS
HOURS TALKING TO PEOPLE ACROSS
MY SENATE DISTRICT THAT ARE
OFTEN NOT HEARD. FROM AND FOR
THOSE REASONS I AM SADDENED TO
OPPOSE SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
TODAY. BUT I'D LIKE TO SHARE
WITH YOU WHY. MY SENATE
DISTRICT TESTY FOURTEEN. IS
HOME TO SEVENTY THOUSAND. SMALL
BUSINESSES. ONE THIRD OF THEM
ARE MINORITY OWNED. CALIFORNIA
SMALL BUSINESSES ARE STRUGGLING
DURING THIS TIME AND THEIR
EMPLOYEES ARE TO. IN MAKING MY
DECISION I TOOK INTO
CONSIDERATION THE STORIES OF
THE PEOPLE I REPRESENT. AND I'D
LIKE TO SHARE WITH YOU A FEW.
CHONG HE A SMALL BUSINESS
FARMER AND FRESNO COUNTY THAT
IS STRUGGLING TO AND TO MAKE
ENDS MEET. HE MAKES UP JUST ONE
OF TWO THOUSAND ASIAN FARMERS
AND FRESNO COUNTY ALONE. CHUNKY
HAS RECEIVED NO SUPPORT OR
FEDERAL AID. TECHNICAL LITERACY
HAS BEEN A MAJOR CHALLENGE TO
RESOURCES AND INFORMATION. A
FARMER THAT WAS FORCED OUT OF
HIS NATIVE HOME BUT HAS BEEN
FIGHTING AND LOOKING FORWARD TO
LIVING THE AMERICAN DREAM. I
ALSO SPOKE WITH A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER ARIANNA. WHO IS
ALSO JUST TRYING TO SEEK
OPPORTUNITIES FOR HER HER
FAMILY AND HER EMPLOYEES. SEC
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS I HAVE
THOUGHT ABOUT ALL THE SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS WE DON'T
USUALLY HEAR FROM OR WE DON'T
THINK OF. MAYBE SOME OF US TOO
BUT- I THOUGHT ABOUT. YOU KNOW
THE MEAT MARKET SECOND THE CITY
S. THE TACO TRUCKS. ALL THOSE
OWNERS BUSINESS OWNERS WHO DO
NOT SPEAK ENGLISH WHO CARE
ABOUT THEIR EMPLOYEES AND WHO
THE EMPLOYEES CARE ABOUT THEM
AS WELL. THE COLLEAGUES I
CANNOT SUPPORT THIS BILL IN THE
CURRENT FORMAT BUT HOLD FOR
NEEDED AMENDMENTS TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION THE PEOPLE THAT
WE DON'T OFTEN HEAR FROM THAT
WILL ALSO BE IMPACTED. WE CAN
ALL WIN. BUT WE MUST LISTEN TO
EACH OTHER. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR HER TITLE. MADAM
PRO TEM. MADAM PRESIDENT MUCH
ON A PART TIME I APOLOGIZE I
THINK YOU WANT TO HAVE A LAST
WORD ON THIS I JUST SAW SENATOR
COVER EUROS MICROPHONE WHAT I'M
GOOD OKAY EXCELLENT PLEASE
THANK MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE. AND I APPLAUD THE
COMMITMENT OF OUR GOVERNOR ON
THIS ISSUE AND HIS- COMMITMENT
AND COURAGE I ALSO WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THE AUTHOR FROM SANTA
BARBARA- THIS IS BEEN AN ISSUE
THAT SHE HAS CHAMPION FOR MANY
YEARS SO THERE'S BEEN PLENTY OF
DISCUSSION. ON THIS ISSUE. YOU
KNOW SIXTEEN YEARS AGO SENATOR
SHE LOOK YOU'LL PUT CALIFORNIA
ON THE MAP ON FAMILY LEAVE WHEN
SHE AUTHORED AND PASS THE
NATION'S VERY FIRST PAID FAMILY
LEAVE PROGRAM. IT WAS AN
ACHIEVEMENT HAVING CALIFORNIA
LEAD ON THIS ISSUE. BUT THAT
WAS JUST THE BEGINNING OF WORK
ON THIS ISSUE. THEY'VE BEEN A
NUMBER OF SUBSEQUENT BILLS BUT
NOTHING BIGGER THAN WHAT WE'RE
ABOUT TO VOTE ON TODAY. EVERY
WORKER IN CALIFORNIA PAYS TAXES
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE BENEFIT OF
BEING ABLE TO TAKE A LEAVE. TO
CARE FOR THEIR CHILD AFTER
BIRTH OR SICK FAMILY MEMBER. AS
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS ARE
DOING RIGHT NOW IN THE MIDDLE
OF THIS PANDEMIC. THE PROBLEM
IS TOO MANY WORKERS ARE UNABLE
TO OBTAIN THE BENEFIT THAT THEY
PAY FOR I THINK MY COLLEAGUE
FROM EAST LA MADE COMMENTS
DIRECTLY TO THIS POINT.
PROVIDING A MOTHER WITH THE
ABILITY TO RETURN TO THEIR JOB
TWELVE WEEKS AFTER GIVING BIRTH
TO ME IS SIMPLY WRITING A
SOCIETAL WRONG. THAT HAS NEVER
BEEN FIXED. DOES IT MEAN THAT
IT'S EASY OR THAT IT DOESN'T
COME WITHOUT COST AND
CHALLENGES FOR BUSINESS.FOR
THE COMMUNITY FOR SOCIETY NO I
KNOWLEDGE THE CHALLENGES BUT I
OWN LIFE EXPERIENCE. MY MOTHER
DIDN'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO TAKE
LEAVE WHEN ME. AND MY SIBLINGS
WERE BORN. MY SISTER WASN'T
ABLE TO TAKE LEAVE AFTER MY
NEPHEW WAS BORN AND INSTEAD I
TOOK THAT RESPONSIBILITY TO
CARE FOR MY NEPHEW SO SHE
COULD. RETURN TO DUTY. I AS A
NAVY ENSIGN. AND SHE DIDN'T
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT HER CHILD
SHE KNEW THAT THAT THAT HER SON
WOULD BE TAKING CARE OF. YOU
KNOW I THOUGHT IT A GREAT DEAL
ABOUT MY MOM THESE LAST TWO
WEEKS YOU KNOW TALKING ABOUT
HER BEING A GARMENT WORKER LAST
WEEK. IN NINETEEN NINETY FOUR
MY MOM DIED OF CANCER. MY
SISTER WAS TAKING CARE OF HER
AND HER HUSBAND AT THE SAME
TIME. BOTH ARE BOTH DIED WITHIN
A TWO WEEK PERIOD. I HAD TO
WORK. I SAW MY MOM IN MAY IN
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR BEFORE SHE
DIED IN AUGUST. BY JULY TWENTY
EIGHTH I GOT A CALL FROM MY
SISTER HER HUSBAND HAD DIED AND
BECAUSE THEY WERE POLICIES THAT
ALLOWED ME TO GO FOR
BEREAVEMENT LEAVE. I COULD GO.
TO MY SISTER'S HUSBAND'S
FUNERAL AND I WAS VERY SAD BUT
I WAS ALSO REALLY EXCITED I WAS
GOING TO SEE MY MOTHER ONE MORE
TIME I KNEW THAT I WOULD GET TO
SEE HER ONE MORE TIME. BEFORE
SHE DIED. I GOT TO TENNESSEE MY
MOM. HAD BECOME COMATOSE. AND
DIED A WEEK LATER. SO EIGHT YOU
KNOW THESE HAVE REAL IMPACTS ON
FAMILY MEMBERS. I CAN'T HELP
BUT WONDER HOW THE LOTS OF MY
FAMILY AND MILLIONS OF OTHERS
WILL BE DIFFERENT. IF MOM'S
WERE ABLE TO TAKE THE TIME TO
BE A MOTHER BEFORE RETURNING TO
WORK OR IF A FAMILY MEMBER HAD
THEABILITY TO BE THERE IN THE
LAST MOMENTS OF A FAMILY
MEMBER'S LIFE SOMETHING YOU
DON'T GET TO DO OVER. THERE NO
DO OVERS. YOU KNOW- I WOULD
JUST COMMENT ON TO THE POINTS
MADE BACK COLLEAGUES. YOU KNOW
ARBITRARY TO MINUS OF EMPLOYERS
IS IT CONSIST NOR INSURED.
HUNDREDS OF YEARS OF PROOF OF
ABUSE OF EMPLOYEES WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT THE EMPLOYERS TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO IT. MANY
EMPLOYERS HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO DO IT BECAUSE THEY CARE
ABOUT THEIR WORKERS THOSE
AREN'T EMPLOYERS OR EMPLOYEES.
EMPLOYERS THAT WE'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT. I RECOGNIZE THAT. AND
ANOTHER POINT. YOU KNOW PRIVATE
BUSINESS REQUIRES WORKERS. IT
IS A SYMBIOTIC RELATIONSHIP
THAT. TO BE SUCCESSFUL AND GET
THEIR NEEDS MET YOU CAN'T HAVE
A SUCCESSFUL BUSINESS WITHOUT
WORKERS. AND SO YOU KNOW
THERE'S NO REVENUE IF THERE'S
NO SYMBIOTIC RELATIONSHIP FOR
ANY OF US TO DIVIDE UP OR THINK
ABOUT OR DISCUSS WHO SHOULD PAY
WIDEN. WHAT A MOUNTAIN AND ALL
OF THOSE THINGS RELATED TO HOW
WE HAVE THOSE DEBATES AND
DISCUSSIONS. SO TODAY I GET AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CAST A VOTE TO
PROVIDE OVER EIGHT MILLION
CALIFORNIANS THE ABILITY TO DO
WHAT MY MOM AND MY SISTER WERE
ABLE TO DO AND HOPEFULLY THOSE
FAMILIES NOT TO HAVE TO THINK
ABOUT. MAKING DECISIONS AS TO
WHETHER THE GUY TAKE OFF WHAT
THEY'RE ABLE TO ARE NOT TO BE
THERE. AT A CRITICAL MOMENT. SO
FOR THAT REASON I WOULD ASK OF
VOTE TODAY ON SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU SENATOR
ATKINS CENTER CABALLERO. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I'M QUITE
FRANKLY I. WASN'T GONNA STAND
UP AND SPEAK BUT- I FEEL
COMPELLED TO. WHEN THE CHARGE
AGAINST ME IF I DON'T VOTE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND I'VE
BEEN VERY FRANK. IN ALL THE
HEARINGS THAT I HAVE BEEN AS
BOTH CHAIR OF SOME FOUR. AND IN
THE BUDGET. THAT I HAVE SERIOUS
CONCERNS WITH THIS. BUT TO-
HAVE THE IMPLICATION. NO IT
WASN'T THE IMPLICATION IT WAS
ACTUALLY STATEMENT. THAT I WAS
NOT A GOOD DEMOCRAT FOR A GOOD
MEMBER OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
QUITE FRANKLY OFFENDS ME AND SO
I HAVE TO STAND UP AND SAY SAY
THAT- LIKE MAY MY GOOD FRIEND
FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY I HAVE
SPENT A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
TIME OVER THE PAST. SIX WEEKS
SPEAKING TO SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS IN MY COMMUNITY NOT
BECAUSE- I WAS DOING THE
OUTREACH BUT BECAUSE QUITE
FRANKLY THEY WERE CALLING ME IN
PANIC. MANY OF THEM WILL NEVER
OPEN AGAIN. MANY OF THEM ARE
STRUGGLING TO STAY AFLOAT
DURING THESE VERY VERY
DIFFICULT TIME. AND THEIR
IMPLORING ME TO DO EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE DURING THE TIME THAT
WE'RE IN SESSION. TO HELP THEM
TO FIND THEM THE RESOURCES TO
BE ABLE TO CONTINUE I HAVE
ALMOSTA HUNDRED THOUSAND SMALL
BUSINESSES IN MY DISTRICT. AND
A MAJORITY OF THOSE SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE IMMIGRANTS. THEY
ARE PEOPLE WHO HAVE COME FROM
OTHER COUNTRIES. AND QUITE
FRANKLY ARE REALLY STRUGGLING
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WITH THE
RULES. THAT WE IMPOSE ON SMALL
BUSINESSES. AND MANY OF THEM
ARE GOOD FRIENDS OF MINE. AND
SO THE MOMENT THAT AN EMPLOYEE
UNDER THIS BILL SHOWS UP AND
SAYS LOOK I GOT TO BE DONE I
NEED TO LEAVE TOMORROW. I NEED
I'M GONNA TAKE LEAVE. AND THAT
EMPLOYER NOT UNDERSTANDING WHAT
THE RULES ARE SAYS HEY WAIT CAN
YOU WAIT TILL FRIDAY. OR SO BUT
YOU'RE FIRED I NEED YOU I'VE
GOT SOMETHING COMING UP THAT I
REALLY NEED YOU FOR I NEED TO
I'M GONNA HAVE TO FILL THAT
POSITION THEY'RE IN VIOLATION
OF THE LAW. AND THE PROBLEM IS
THAT USUALLY IN THE CONSTRUCT
THAT WE HAVE DONE THESE FAMILY
LEAVE BILLS. IS IT HAS BEEN.
EIGHTY REFERRAL TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
HOUSING. AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE
DATA. THAT THEY HAVE PROVIDED
THIS LEGISLATURE THEY DO NOT
HAVE A BACKLOG. OF CASES AND
QUITE FRANKLY THEY RESOLVE
CASES VERY QUICKLY AND THEY
HAVE A MEDIATION UNIT SO THAT
THEY CAN SIT DOWN AND WALK YOU
THROUGH AND TELL SMALL BUSINESS
EMPLOYERS HERE'S WHAT SHOULD
HAPPEN BUT INSTEAD WHAT WE DID
IN THIS BILL IS WE CREATED A
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION. WHICH
MEANS YOU CAN HIRE YOUR OWN
ATTORNEY YOU CAN SUE AND THEN
ALL OF A SUDDEN OU'RE STARTING
TO GET DAMAGES FROM THE SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT AND FRANKLY
YOU'RE IN VIOLATION OF THE
LACKEY SAY NO. OR IF YOU SAY
HEY CAN YOU WORK ONE DAY A WEEK
I NEED SOME HELP I DON'T WANT
TO HAVE TO REPLACE YOU SO THE
CHALLENGE THAT I HAVE IS THIS
IS FROM THE DAY THAT THIS BILL
HIT. HIT OF MY COMMITTEE. AND
FRANKLY IT'S THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL. AS A BUDGET BILL AND
THE PROCESS IS BEEN. VERY
STRANGE BECAUSE NORMALLY THIS
WOULD HAVE GONE THROUGH A
POLICY COMMITTEES AND WE WOULD
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO TALK ABOUT
SOME OF THE STUFF IN A POLICY
CONTEXT. IT HASN'T BEEN
PROVIDED IT WE HAVEN'T HAD THAT
BECAUSE NUMBER ONE THERE'S BEEN.
AB RELUCTANCE TO NEGOTIATE SO
THE ONE THE ONE AMENDMENT
FRANKLY WAS TO GO FROM ONE
EMPLOYEE TO FIVE DOESN'T MAKE
ME HAPPY I'D RATHER HAVE IT.
THE PERTAINED ALL OF THE
EMPLOYEES THIS THIS IS A. A
POLICY I WANT TO SUPPORT. BUT
THE WAY THE BILL IS WRITTEN IS
FLAWED AND WE HAVEN'T HAD A
CHANCE TO REALLY MAKE THE
DIFFERENCE THE CORRECTIONS THAT
NEED TO BE MADE. IN ORDER FOR
IT TO ACTUALLY WORK FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES AS WELL. AND SO. I
REGRETTABLY STAND HERE. AND SAY
ON BEHALF OF MY- ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND SMALL BUSINESSES IN MY
DISTRICT. BUT WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THIS RIGHT.
AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE EMPLOYEES ARE
PROTECTED THAT THEY HAVE THE
RIGHT TO TAKE THIS LEAVE THAT
THEY HAVE THEIR JOB PROTECTED
THAT THEY GET PAID THE MONEY
THEY PAID INTO THE PROGRAM AND
THAT SMALL BUSINESSES ARE
PROTECTED IN THE WHOLE PROCESS
AND IF WE CAN'T DO THAT I THINK
WE OUGHT TO. PUT THIS ON THE
SLOW TRACK. DEAL WITH THIS IS A
POLICY BILL. TAKE OUR TIME.
BRING IT BACK AND WORKING
THROUGH THE PROCESS SO THAT WE
CAN GET IT DONE BY AUGUST I
RESPECTFULLY ASK A NO VOTE
THANK YOU SIR CABALLERO SENATOR
GONZALEZ. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES AND I
APPRECIATE THAT THE DIALOGUE
THAT- BEEN HAD TODAY BY MANY OF
MY COLLEAGUES AND I THINK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA BARBARA
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND
REALLY FIGHTING THE GOOD FIGHT
WHEN IT COMES TO LEAVE POLICIES
HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I WHOLEHEARTEDLY
SUPPORT SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE. AND I'D BE REMISS IF I
DIDN'T INCLUDE- SOME
INFORMATION NOT ONLY ABOUT
MYSELF BUT OF COURSE ABOUT OF
THE FOSTER PARENTS THAT ARE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA MANY OF
WHICH WERE NOT ONLY MY FRIENDS
BUT MANY ARE WHO ARE MY
CONSTITUENTS THE FIRST. YOU
KNOW COMING FROM A LARGE
CORPORATION I WAS PERSONALLY
GIVEN ABOUT FIVE YEARS AND AGO
WHEN I HAD MY CHILD. TWENTY
WEEKS OF PAID LEAVE. TWENTY
WEEKS THAT COULD BE TAKEN. I
DIDN'T HAVE TO BE TAKEN
CONSECUTIVELY NOW I KNOW THAT
WAS A LARGE CORPORATION THAT. A
COULD BEAR THE BRUNT OF THESE
LEAVE POLICIES BUT I THINK IT
WAS A BIG TELLER. ESPECIALLY
COMING FROM A HUGE TECH GIANT
THAT SAID YES WE CARE. ABOUT
OUR EMPLOYEES AND WE WANT TO
SEE CHANGE WE WANT TO SEE THEM
COME BACK- HAPPY WE WANT TO SEE
THEM COME BACK WITH THEIR WELL
BEING A PRIORITY. NEXT DAY I
DIGRESS TO THE FOSTER PARENTS
UP MANY OF OUR WHO ARE WHO ARE
MY FRIENDS. AND WHO SAID TO ME
THAT OFTENTIMES LIFE IS NOT
TWELVE CONSECUTIVE WEEKS WITH
FOSTERING. AS A NO YOU KNOW
THEY GET A CALL FROM A HOSPITAL
OR FOR CHILD PROTECTIVE
SERVICES. AND IT'S YOU HAVE TO
BE AT THE HOSPITAL IN ONE HOUR.
AND MAYBE THEY'VE EXHAUSTED ALL
OF THEIR LEAVE. AND WHAT DID
THEY HAVE TO DO. EITHER HAVE TO
DECIDE WHETHER TO GO AND PICK
UP THAT CHILD OR THEY HAVE TO
DECIDE TO LOSE THEIR JOB IN
MANY CASES. AND IN THE MIDST OF
SUCH A PAINFUL AND VULNERABLE
TIME CHILDREN WHO ENTER FOSTER
CARE DESERVE THE TIME. TO
PROCESS TO GRIEVE AND DEVELOP A
SENSE OF SAFETY. THEY ALSO HAVE
A REALLY- NEED TIME TO ENSURE
THAT THEY ARE TRANSITIONING
INTO SOCIETY WITH THIS NEW HOME
LIFE APPROPRIATELY. AND WITH
THAT I CERTAINLY ASK. FOR
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR GONZALEZ CENTER CHECK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
UNFORTUNATELY I RISE IN
OPPOSITION AND I JUST WANT TO
SAY YOU KNOW MANY OF YOU KNOW
THAT I SUPORT PAID FAMILY
LEAVE I SUPPORTED- PAY FAMILY
BENEFIT PAID FAMILY LEAVE
BENEFIT EXPANSION AND I ALSO
WANT TO THANK SENATE THE
SENATOR FROM SANTA BARBARA
BECAUSE I KNOW SHE'S BEEN
WORKING ON THIS FOR MANY YEARS
AND I AM WITH HER.
UNFORTUNATELY I HAVE TO AGREE
WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM- FROM
SALINAS- IN TERMS OF THE
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION YOU
KNOW I EVEN TURN MY OWN BILL OF
REGARDING PAID FAMILY LEAVE SB
NINE FORTY THREE WHICH WAS HELD
A WHICH WOULD ALLOW FOR PARENTS
RECEIVE BENEFITS OF FROM PAID
FAMILY LEAVE DUE TO HAVING TO
CARE FOR CHILDDEPENDENT- OR
DEPENDING WHO SCHOOLS ARE
CLOSED AND- IN ADDRESSING OF
THE SENATOR FROM CONTRA COSTA.
YOU KNOW I WOULD BE THERE IF IT
WAS A IF THIS IS THIS BILLS
ADDRESSING OF THE COVERT
SITUATION AND I OFF ALSO HEARD
FROM MANY SMALL BUSINESSES AND
PERMISSION TO READ. WITHOUT
OBJECTION I HAVE A LETTER I
JUST RECEIVED IT AND IT. SHE'S
SHE'S A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER IN
BREA. SAID I HAVE NEVER REACHED
OUT FOR HELP FROM ANYONE BUT I
AM AT RISK LOSING OF LOSING
EVERYTHING DUE TO COVER
NINETEEN. I MANUFACTURE
CHILDREN'S KEEPS KEEPS A GIFT
PRODUCT THAT I DESIGN AND SELL
THEM VERY SUCCESSFULLY TO
RETAIL MARKETS WHICH INCLUDES
ALL OF THE SMALL MOM AND POP
STORES TROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY.
THAT KEPT ME IN BUSINESS OVER
THE PAST THIRTY THREE YEARS.
DUE TO THE COUNTRY RETAIL. DUE
TO THE COUNTRY RETAIL BUSINESS
IS BEING SHUT DOWN I HAVE DONE
EVERYTHING IN MY POWER TO
SURVIVE WE RECEIVED THE P. P.
P. AND HAVE PAID ALL MY
EMPLOYEES I HAVEN'T PAID THEM
BEFORE PPP. MANY OF MY RETAIL
ACCOUNTS HAVE SHUT DOWN MANY
COULD NOT PAY THEIR OPEN
INVOICES TO US ALL DO THE
COVERT NINETEEN. I'M IF A WOMAN
OWNED FAMILY BUSINESS THAT
NEEDS SOME HELP TO SURVIVE. WE
ALSO REQUIRED TO COMPLETE OUR
LEASE AND WE'RE PLANNING ON
DOWNSIZING BUT NEED TO RESOLVE
THE CURRENT FINANCIAL BURDEN. I
CURRENTLY HAVE MY HUSBAND. MY
THREE SONS AND FIVE ADDITIONAL
EMPLOYEES WORKING FOR ME AND
DEPENDING ON NEED TO SURVIVE. I
HAVE I HAVE RECEIVED MANY
EMAILS AND MANY PHONE CALLS.
FROM SIMILAR SMALL BUSINESSES.
I AM IMPLORING US TO SIT DOWN
AND LET'S DO THIS RIGHT BECAUSE
I'M A HUGE SUPPORTER OF PAID
FAMILY LEAVE. AND I WANT TO
VOTE FOR SOMETHING. LIKE THIS
BUT UNFORTUNATELY I CAN'T GET
THERE TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CENTER CHIANG CENTER
BORDERS. TODAY'S DEBATE HAS
BEEN. VERY INSIGHTFUL I
APPRECIATED I'LL KEEP MY
COMMENTS TO A MINIMUM I'M
IMPRESSED BY COMMONSENSE HEARD
FROM LOYAL DEMOCRATS. WHO HAVE
TAKEN A- STRONG STAND ON THIS
ISSUE BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE THAT
WITH MORE DEBATE MORE ON
DISCUSSION. ESPECIALLY THE
PERTAINS TO- PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION THIS COULD BE
DRAMATICALLY IMPROVED UPON. BUT
GIVEN THE OF THE PROCESSES THAT
IT'S GONE THROUGH THE SHORT
CUTS THAT WERE MADE FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS I THINK WE
MIGHT HAVE A PRODUCT. THAT IS
NOT. RIGHT FOR A STABILITY PLAN
TODAY IN OTHER WORDS IT'S AT
THIS POINT IN TIME IS NOT READY
FOR PRIME TIME. SO I WOULD
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE FOLKS. THAT
IN THE AUTHOR. ON TO REVISIT
SOME OF THESE COMPELLING ISSUES
I THINK THERE ARE WAYS TO MAKE
THIS BETTER FROM- THE VIEWPOINT
ACROSS THE AISLE AND I THINK
WOULD IMPROVE UPON THE PRODUCT
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THIS MATTER BE BROUGHT BACK AT
A LATER POINT TIME. THANK YOU
CENTER FOR JUST A SENATOR
NIELSEN. MADAM PRESIDENT LADIES
AND GENTLEMAN OF THE SENATE I
WAS NOT INTENDING TO RISE ON
THE BILL. AND I'M RISING ON THE
BILL BUT MORE I'M RISING
SUPPORTING A COLLEAGUE. THE
LIVE SHARED A COMMON EXPERIENCE.
WE HAS LEGISLATORS HAVE MANY
THINGS TO BALANCE OUR OWN
CONVICTION AND FUNDAMENTAL
BELIEFS WHICH I'VE ALWAYS
ARGUED SHOULD BE PREEMINENT. WE
HAVE THE PARTY THAT WE ARE A
MEMBER OF TO BE RESPECTFUL AND
HELPFUL TO. AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY WE HAVE THE PEOPLE.
THAT WE REPRESENT. NOW WE OF
COURSE CANNOT REPRESENT
EVERYBODY ON ALL ISSUES. WE DO
THE VERY BEST WE CN. TO BE
CONSISTENT. WHEN  FIRST RAN
THE DISTRICT TO DIE. INSPIRED
TO WAS 60% DEMOCRAT 30%
REPUBLICAN. NOT REALLY VERY
GOOD ODDS. BUT IT WORKED OUT
AND I FOUND OUT. THAT I COULD
BE TRUE TO MY CONVICTIONS. NOT
A TRAIT THE PARTY. AND
REPRESENTS A STRONG MAJORITY
DEMOCRATIC DISTRICT. AND KEY TO
THAT WAS BEING ATTENTIVE TO THE
NEEDS OF THE CONSTRUCTION WHICH
WHICH IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING WE DO IT IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN ALL THE
PHILOSOPHIC THINGS OR PARTY
THINGS WE ASPIRE TO AN- OUT
HERE. WELL THEN WE HAD A
REAPPORTIONMENT COME ALONG. AND
THEN IT BECAME A BIT MORE
DIFFICULT BECAUSE THE DISTRICT
BECAME A BIT MORE REPUBLICAN
THEN I THINK THE HIGHEST EVER
GOT WAS 34% BUT THERE WERE MORE
REPUBLICANS. AND UNLIKE THE
MEMBER WHO I'M REFERRING TO
FROM SALINAS. SHE REPRESENTS
VALLEY COUNTIES. AND COASTAL
COUNTIES. I HAD A SIMILAR
CIRCUMSTANCE BECAUSE IN THE
SECOND REAPPORTIONMENT PICKED
UP A LOT OF THE SACRAMENTO
VALLEY COUNTIES WHICH WERE VERY
DIFFERENT. THEN SOME OF THE
FORMER COUNTIES. SO IT WAS A
MORE CHALLENGING. TIME BUT I
DIDN'T PAY ANY ATTENTION TO
THAT. I CAN BY AND WORK WITH%
THE MEMBERS AND THE CITIZENS OF
THE DISTRICT NAY YET INTEREST
THAT WE HAD THERE IN THOSE
DISTRICTS THAT WERE COMMON. AND
TRIED TO BE ATTENTIVE TO THEM.
AND IT WORKED OUT FOR ME. WELL.
I SEE THE PRESSURE THE CHEESE
AND DURING. NOT TO BE
UNEXPECTED. BUT WHAT I WOULD
MOST ASSUREDLY ADD THERE OUGHT
TO BE NO RETALIATION FROM ANY
SOURCE FOR A MEMBER. WHO
SUPPORTS THE DISTRICT THEY
REPRESENT. AND DOES THE VERY
BEST TO DO THAT KNOWING THAT
SOME IN THAT DISTRICT WILL NOT
LIKE WHAT THEY DO. BUT I SHOULD
LET FROM MY PERSONAL EXPERIENCE.
THOUGH THEY MAY NOT LIKE IT.
THEY WILL STILL RESPECT. AN
ELECTRICIAN ONE BIT FURTHER
WITH A BIT OF A HUMOROUS
ADDITION. ONE OF THE
COMMUNITIES THAT I FIRST
REPRESENTED WAS DAVIS. I WON
THE DISTRICT BY 54% BUT LOST IN
DAVIS. BY TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED
VOTES I BELIEVE. NEXT TIME
AROUND. I WON THE DISTRICT LIFE
57% BUT I CARRIED THE DID NOT
KERRY DAVIS. BUT ONLY LOST BY
FIVE HUNDRED VOTES. WELL THE
PRESIDENT IS A BIG DEAL SO THEY
COME IN THEY SAID WHAT WHAT
WHAT WHAT SET NIELSEN- YOU'RE
THE ONLY LOST BY FIVE HUNDRED
AND DAVIS. I SAID YEAH I'M
AFRAID I'M I'M GETTING OUT OF
TUNE WITH THE DISTRICT I'M
GOING TO WORK REALLY HARD THE
NEXT FOUR YEARS THE LOSE BY A
GREATER MARGIN AND DAVIS. NEXT
TIME. NOW THAT SPOKEN FUN AT
IT. BUT IT WOULDN'T BEEN
INDIFFERENCE HAD I STAYED
REPRESENTING DAVIS YOU ATTEND
TO THE- POPULATION. THE END AND
THAT'S WHAT MADE A DIFFERENCE
TO ME THAT THAN QUANTIFIES HOW
ONE CAN SUCCESSFULLY BALANCE.
FROM VERY DIFFERENT INTEREST IN
THE DISTRICT THAT THEY
REPRESENT. AND FURTHER WHY IT
IS IMPORTANT FOR A MEMBER TO DO
THAT. AND THAT NUMBER IS
COMMENDABLY BALANCING THOSE
CONCERNS AND THAT ARGUES I
THINK TO A NO VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER NIELSEN MEMBER SEEING NO
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CENTER JACKSON YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND I
REALLY O APPRECIATE THIS
ROBUST AND HARDY DEBATE I AM
TOTALLY CONVINCED THAT MY SEVEN
AND FOUR YEAR OLD GRAND
CHILDREN HAVE LOST INTEREST
THOUGH IN THIS DISCUSSION.
GIVEN THE AMOUNT OF TIME THAT
WE HAVE SPENT ON IT- BUT I DO
THINK IT'S A WORTHY DISCUSSION
AND I WANT TO APPRECIATE. THOSE
IN SUPPORT AS WELL AS THOSE.
WHO ARE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL I DO THINK THIS IS A
QUESTION OF WHAT OUR PRIORITIES
MORE. AND THAT'S WHY I AM IN
EARNEST IN STRONG SUPPORT AND
HOPE THAT ULTIMATELY. YOU WILL
ALSO A VOTE FOR THIS BILL AS
WELL WHAT I WANT TO DO IS TO
ADDRESS. SOME OF THEM
MISUNDERSTANDING. THAT EXISTS
FIRST OF ALL THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT REQUIRES
FURTHER. ANALYSIS THIS ISSUE
HAS BEEN AN HOUR ANALYZE FOR
YEARS FOR DECADES. THE STUDIES
THAT FORM THE BASIS UPON WHICH
THE GOVERNOR'S TASK FORCE
SUGGESTED THIS LEGISLATION HAVE
GONE ON FOR YEARS. THERE ARE AT
LEAST FOUR FIVE THAT I'VE READ
THAT WERE WRITTEN IN THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS THE DEAL WITH AND
GO BACK TO EARLIER THE SKY. AND
EARLIER RESEARCH THAT WAS DONE
THIS ISSUE HAS BEEN RESEARCHED
TO THE MAXIMUM. IT SHOWS THAT
GIVING NEW PARENT LEAVE IS GOOD
FOR THE FOR THE INFANT IS GOOD
FOR THE MOTHER. REDUCING POST
PARTUM DEPRESSION BY THIRD AND
GOOD FOR A NEW DAD. AND WE'RE
SEEING MORE MORE DADS TAKING
THIS LEAVE. SO THE RESEARCHERS
THERE. THIS LEGISLATION AGAIN
HAS TAKEN A LOOK AT THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE A PAID FAMILY
LEAVE PROGRAM BUT A LOT OF
PEOPLE DON'T ACCESS IT IN THE
ROOM THE REASON IS BECAUSE
THERE'S NO ASSURANCE THAT GOT
THE JOB. AND THIS ESSENTIALLY
PUTS THE CAP ON BACK CONSERVE.
IT ADDRESSES IT IT'S A TWO FOLD
THE ISSUE. THE ABILITY TO TAKE
LEAVE THE TO PAY FOR. AND BE
SURE YOU GET YOUR JOB WHEN YOU
COME BACK. THAT'S WHAT THIS IS.
THIS ISN'T ABOUT AB FIVE
BECAUSE TEMPORARY EMPLOYEES ARE
NOT SUBJECT TO THE INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTOR ISSUE. AB FIVE IS
NOT AN ISSUE. AND LIKE MANY OF
YOU I'VE ACTUALLY HAD A SMALL
BUSINESS TO. AND I HAVE STORIES
OF MY STAFF NEEDING TO GO OUT
ON LEAVE. THEY DON'T JUST CALL
UP AND SAY I'VE GOT TO TAKE
TWELVE WEEKS OFF. THERE ARE
REQUIREMENTS UNDER THIS
LEGISLATION. THERE ARE
REQUIREMENTS. THAT IF YOU. HAVE
AN EMERGENCY. THEN YOU CAN TAKE
THAT EMERGENCY TIME OFF BUT
OTHERWISE YOU HAVE TO GIVE AT
LEAST THIRTY DAYS NOTICE LET ME
MAKE SURE I HAVE THIS CORRECT.
YOU HAVE TO GIVE AT LEAST
THIRTY DAYS NOTICE- IF BELIEVE
IS PREDICTABLE. SO IF YOU'RE
GOING TO TAKE LEE BECAUSE YOU
ARE GOING TO HAVE A BABY. NOW
MOST PEOPLE WILL TELL THEIR
EMPLOYERS WHEN THEY FIND OUT.
THIS IS A JOYFUL MOMENT FOR
MOST PEOPLE. AND THEY ARE GOING
TO SHARE WITH THEIR EMPLOYER
HEY LOOK. I AM GOING TO HAVE A
BABY ON TWO X. POINT AND I
WOULD LIKE TO TAKE MY LEAVE AT
THAT POINT IN TIME. NOW ONE OF
THE THINGS WE HAVE TO REMEMBER
TO BY THE WAY. IS THAT A GOOD
PORTION OF THIS LEAVE IS UNPAID.
SO PEOPLE ARE JUST GOING TO RUN
OUT AND START TAKING LEAVE.
THEY DON'T GET PAID WHEN THEY
TAKE THAT LEAVES. THEY CAN GET
PARTIAL JOB REPLACEMENT FROM
THEIR OWN MONEY FROM THEIR
SAVINGS ACCOUNT BUT FOR A LOT
OF PEOPLE PARTICULARLY LOW
INCOME WORKERS THAT ISN'T
ENOUGH TO MAKE THEIR ENDS MEET
PEOPLE TAKE THIS LEAVE BECAUSE
THEY NEED TO TAKE A SWING. THEY
TAKE THIS LEAVE BECAUSE THEY
HAVE A FAMILY MEMBER. IT WAS
MENTIONED BY MY GOOD COLLEAGUE
FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY THAT
SHE WAS ABLE TO TAKE HER MOTHER
FOR CANCER TREATMENTS. ARE
THOSE TREATMENTS OF COURSE ARE
USUALLY SCHEDULED IN ADVANCE
AND IF YOU NEED TO TAKE A
FRIDAY OFF EVERY OTHER WEEK.
FOR TO TAKE A PARENT FOR CANCER
TREATMENT OR IF YOU NEED YOUR
OWN CANCER TREATMENT. AS SOME
OF US IN THIS ROOM HAVE HAD.
YOU KNOW WHEN THOSE TREATMENTS
OR AND YOU DESPERATELY NEED TO
TAKE THAT TIME OFF FROM WORK IN
PART FRANKLY BECAUSE YOU'RE
TREATING YOUR EMPLOYER IF YOU
GO BACK TO WORK WHEN YOU'RE
FEELING CRAPPY. LET'S FACE IT
ALL OF US IN THIS ROOM EITHER
OURSELVES OR OUR LOVED ONES
HAVE HAD THOSE MOMENTS WHERE WE
NEED TO BE THERE FOR THEM. AND
IF YOU AREN'T THERE FOR THEM.
YOU WILL HAVE MISSED OUT ON
BOTH THE JOY AND THE
RESPONSIBILITY. OF CARING FOR
THE PEOPLE THAT YOU LOVE. SO
THE NOTION THAT AN EMPLOYER.
SHOULD BE ABLE TO TELL YOU.
WHEN YOU CAN TAKE THAT LEAVE.
IS A QUESTION YOU HAVE TO ASK
YOURSELF. YOU DON'T JUST TAKE
LEAVE BECAUSE SHE WANTED THE
LAW REQUIRES THAT YOU'RE TAKING
IT FOR A MAJOR MEDICAL REASON
YOU'VE GOT TO BE ABLE TO
DEMONSTRATE THAT. OR WHAT DO
YOU WANT TO BOND WITH THE
NEWBORN AS A MOTHER OR A
FATHER. AN INCH TODAY'S WORLD
WE KNOW THAT OUR PEOPLE ARE NOT
ABLE TO BE IN THE WORK FORCE
THEIR FAMILY SUFFER. AND WE DO
KNOW. AND THE RESEARCH IS CLEAR
THAT THERE IS A BENEFIT TO
SMALL BUSINESSES. TO BE ABLE TO
GIVE. THEIR EMPLOYEES THE TIME
OFF AND BRING THEM BACK WITHOUT
HAVING TO GET NEW EMPLOYEES THE
COST OF RETENTION OR EXCUSE ME
THE COST OF RETRAINING. THE
COST OF GOING OUT AND TRYING TO
FIND NEW PEOPLE. IS STEPS. TO
THESE COME IN THE RESEARCH
SHOWS THAT THE COME. EITHER
SMALL COME AND THEY'RE BEEN
STUDIES DONE OF THIS AND I
APPRECIATE THAT MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE TALKED TO SOME OF THEIR
WORK OUR SMALL BUSINESSES. BUT
IF THEY HAVE BEEN THROUGH THIS
THOSE SMALL BUSINESSES WILL
TELL YOU THAT ACTUALLY THEY
WERE ABLE TO SAVE MONEY. AND
THAT THEIR WORKERS COME BACK
THERE MORE EFFECTIVE THE MORE
EFFICIENT THEY'RE MORE LOYAL
THEY STAY LONGER IN THE JOB
THOSE ARE THE FACTS. WE KNOW
THAT. SO I WANT TO GET TO THE
ISSUE OF A PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION. THERE'S ALWAYS A SEEMS
TO BE A STICKING POINT FOR SOME
OFMY COLLEAGUES IN MY A GOOD
COLLEAGUE. WHO ASKED ME TO
DIRECT MY ATTENTION TO THAT IN
MY CLOTHES SO I HOPE THAT SHE
IS. LISTENING BECAUSE I WANT TO
ADDRESS THIS. A PRIVATE RIGHT
OF ACTION HAS BEEN IN THE LAW
SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT.
WITH THE ARE APPARENT
DISABILITY MATERNITY DISABILITY
LEAVE HAS A PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION. SO THIS IS NOT NEW TO
EMPLOYERS BUT WHAT IS THAT ME.
UNDER THE LAW AND UNDER THIS
FLOOR HERE IT MEANS THAT IF YOU
FEEL THAT YOUR RIGHT TO TAKE
THAT LEAVE HAS BEEN VIOLATED
YOU HAVE TO FILE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING. THEY GO THROUGH AN
INVESTIGATION. THEY ALSO OFFER
MEDIATION. SO IF YOU ARE IN
MEDIATION YOUR SMALL EMPLOYER
YOU DIDN'T KNOW YOU HAD TO DO
THIS YOU WERE IN MEDIATION AND
YOU SAY OH MY GOODNESS I'VE GOT
TO GIVE YOU YOUR JOB BACK HERE
IS YOUR JOB BACK THEN THE
EMPLOYEE HAS NO DAMAGES. SO
EFFECTIVELY THE SITUATION HAS
BEEN RESOLVED. HOW FREQUENTLY
USE THIS USED VERY VERY RARELY.
BECAUSE EMPLOYEES DON'T WANT TO
SUE YOU THEY JUST WANT TO TAKE
THE TIME OFF THE BOND WITH A
NEWBORN OR TO TAKE CARE OF A
PARENT OR A CHILD. THREE ME. I
MEAN I THINK WE ALL HAVE THOSE
STORIES AND TO SAY THAT
EMPLOYERS GIVE YOU THAT RIGHT
WELL IF THAT WERE THE CASE WE
WOULDN'T BE HERE BUT I CAN
ASSURE YOU AND ALL THE YEARS
I'VE BEEN DOING THIS WORK AND
THE DOZENS IF NOT TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE
COME BEFORE COMMITTEES ARE TO
TESTIFY. THE ANGUISH OF THEIR
INABILITY TO TAKE THE LEAVE I
REMEMBER WE HAD A FIRE FIGHTER
WHO HAD BEEN A CAPTAIN AND HE
BECAME THE SOLE SUPPORT AND THE
SHOW PROVIDER FOR HIS THREE
YOUNG SONS. AND HE HAD TO WORK
HIS SCHEDULE AROUND THE HIS
CHILDREN. AND HE WAS FIRED
BECAUSE OF THAT. HE WAS ONE OF
MY WITNESSES WHO CAME IN A DAD
WHO JUST WANTED TO BE ABLE TO
WORK SO THAT HE COULD CARE FOR
HIS CHILDREN AS WELL. AND I
THINK AS WE- BORROWED DOWN INTO
THIS. WE HAVE TO BE COGNIZANT
OF THE FACT. IN THIS WORLD
TODAY IN ALL OF THE INDUSTRIAL
COUNTRIES OF THE WORLD OTHER
THAN THE UNITED STATES.
COMPANIES GOVERNMENT'S POLICY.
ALLOWS PEOPLE TO BE BOTH. AN
EMPLOYEE AND A HUMAN BEING AND
THAT IS WHAT I AM ASKING YOU TO
VOTE FOR TODAY AND WITH THAT I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIFLE THANK YOU CENTER JACKSON
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN ARCHULETA HI ATKINS
I FELL. I FORGES NO BRADFORD.
CUT BY ADAM NO CHIANG NOTE
DALLY NO DODD. NO DRAWS THEM I
GALGIANI. GLAZER NO GONZALEZ I
GROWTH NO HERTZBERG. I HILL. I
HUESO HI HER TADO NO JACKSON I
JONES NO LEYVA HI MCGUIRE AYE
MELENDEZ NO MITCHELL. I MONEY I
MORE LOOK NO MORALE. NIELSEN NO
HAN HI PORTANTINO I ROTH. RUBIO
SKINNER I STERN HI NUMBER. WHY
CASKEY HI WIENER HI WILK.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN I BRADFORD. GALGIANI
MORRELL. ROTH RUBIO. I BURKE.
WILK. I TWENTY ONE KNOWS TWELVE
THE MEASURE PASSES. I'M SORRY
US SENATOR. OKAY MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO DO AND THE JOURNEY IN
MEMORY TODAY WE LOST ONE OF OUR
OWN ASSEMBLYMEMBER BILL
DUPLICITY AND WE HAVE TO
MEMBERS WHO ARE GOING TO SPEAK
ON THIS JOURNEY MEMORY ONE IS
SENATOR GRAHAM AND THE OTHER IS
SENATOR BRADFORD I WILL START
WITH SENATOR GROVE. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AND I'D ALSO
LIKE TO THANK THE SENATE PRO
TEMPORE A LAO IN MYSELF IN
CENTER BRADFORD TO SHARE. JUST
A FEW COMMENTS ABOUT- BILL TO
PLEASE SEE HE SERVED IN THE
HOUSE IN THE IN THE ASSEMBLY IN
A- HE SERVED UNDER WILLIE BROWN
AND- IF THERE WASN'T A TIME.
THAT YOU COULDN'T RUN INTO BILL
WITH HIS HAT ON HIS HEAD OR HIS
THREE PIECE SUIT. N. B. JUST
INFECTED BY HIS KINDNESS HIS-
G. ONE. OF LOVE AND COMPASSION
FOR PEOPLE HE WAS TRULY AND IT
DIDN'T MATTER WHAT PARTY YOU
CAME FROM. IT DIDN'T MATTER ANY
IT NO ONE GET IT DIDN'T KNOW
EITHER NO ONE WAS IT. IMMUNE
FROM HIS INFECTIOUS PERSONALITY
EN LOS BITING HIS HAT IN THE
HALLWAY MEANT ONE THING THAT
YOU KNOW A COMFORTING SWEET
COMPASSIONATE HAD- WE STARTED
LOSING WEIGHT HE WAS KIND OF
MODELING HIS THREE PIECE SUIT
EVERYWHERE YOU WENT LOOKING FOR
COMPLIMENTS HE WAS A VERY FAIR
AS A LOBBYIST HE GAVE YOU
INFORMATION- THAT WAS GOOD ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE BILL. HE'D
SAY THIS IS GONNA HURT YEAH BUT
THIS IS WHY NEED TO VOTE FOR IT
HE ADVOCATED PASSIONATELY FOR
ISSUES AND- I CAN JUST IMAGINE-
WHEN THAT HE TOOK HIS LAST
BREATH HERE. IN THE GATES OF
HEAVEN OPENED AT. HE'S THE KIND
OF GUY THE JESUS WOULD MEAN AT
THE GATE PERSONALLY. AND
THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT HE WALKED
IN AND HE PUT HIS ARM AROUND
JESUS AND HE SAID. OVER A
BOTTLE OF ICE STREET BECAUSE
THAT WAS HIS FAVORITE DRINK.
SEVEN A BOTTLE OF THIS ICE
DRINK. AND LET ME TELL YOU A
STORY ABOUT WILLIE BROWN. AND
I'M SURE THE FUNNIEST ONE THAT
HE TOLD ME EVEN REMINISCED
ABOUT IT LAST NIGHT WAS WHEN
THEY ACTUALLY COMMANDEERED
WILLYS CAR IN A TRIP THE
LEGISLATIVE TRIP TO NEW YORK.
AND WILLIE WAS LOOKING ALL OVER
FOR HIS CAR AND LO AND BEHOLD
BILL AND OTHERS HAD HIS CAR.
AND I THINK SHE'S A CITY I KNOW
YOU DID THAT. I NEEDED THAT AND
I THINK. IN EVERY TIME IS THAT
STORY HE ALWAYS HIS KNEE AND
LAUGHTER REAL LOUD. AND THAT
JUST MADE EVERYBODY IN THE ROOM
LAUGH. I KNOW THAT- HE STRUGGLE
WITH SOME BACK ISSUES IN. AND A
COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO WE ALL BUT
AN EMAIL OR CALL FROM STEP HERE
BILLY THAT SAID- THE DOUBTS NOT
DOING GOOD. SEVENTY WORKED WITH
HIM OR YEARS BUT BELIEVE
DOUBTS NOT DOING GOOD. AND SO I
KNOW THAT WE COVERED HIM IN
PRAYER AND DAY. YESTERDAY WE
ALL GOT THE EMAIL THAT HE HAD
AT PASSED AWAY. SO IT'S AN
HONOR TO BE ABLE TO SERVE IN
THIS BUILDING. IN ONCE IN A
GREAT WHILE RENDON TO AN
INDIVIDUAL WITH INTEGRITY AND-
KINDNESS IN GENUINE THIS ENERGY
ONE LOVE FOR ALL PEOPLE IN BILL
DUPLESSIS I REALLY BELIEVE WAS
THAT PERSON. AND SO WE WILL
KEEP A SHARE IN IN BILLION
ELEANOR IN OUR PRAYERS AND- IT
JUST REMEMBER THE GREAT PERSON
THAT BILL DUPLICITY WAS AND
WHAT HE ADDED TO THIS BUILDING
SO THANK YOU AGAIN MADAM PER
TEN. IN CENTER BRADFORD FOR
MAKING THIS DAY HAPPEN THAT WE
GET HONOR THIS GREAT MAN. AT
TODAY ON THIS FLOOR. THANK YOU
SENATOR GROVE CENTER BRADFORD.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. IN
MY TIME IN THE LEGISLATURE I'VE
GOT OPPORTUNITY TO MEET. A LOT
OF AMAZING PEOPLE. BUT I WOULD
HAVE TO SAY. ISSUE THE POLICY
IS PROBABLY THE CREAM OF THE
CROP. WHO'S THE INDIVIDUAL WHO
RESPECTED TO AND LOVE YOU FOR
WHO YOU ARE NOT WHAT YOU DID
NOT WHAT YOU SAID BUT- WHAT YOU
BROUGHT TO THE TABLE. HE WAS
INDIVIDUAL AS ON THIS SENATOR
FROM. BAKER SHOWS CLEARLY
STATED LOVE TO TELL STORIES AND
I DON'T HAVE MANY REGRETS BUT I
WISH I HAD SERVED WITH BILL THE
POLICY. I WOULD CHECK SIR WHEN
THERE WAS A COLLEGIALITY AND
THE FRIENDSHIP AND REALLY
DIDN'T KNOWWE YOUR COLLEAGUES
GET TO KNOW THEIR FAMILY HE
LOVED TELLING WILLIE BROWN
STORIES AND AS EVERYBODY KNOWS
HE WAS A STAUNCH REPUBLICAN BUT
IS ONE OF HIS BEST FRIENDS WAS
WILLIE BROWN. AND ALL THE IN
THE IN THE WE ONLY SERVED. ONE
TERMINAL LEGISLATURE. HE MADE
AN IMPACTFUL A GREAT IMPACT ON
THE- PEOPLE HERE INTHIS TOWN-
HE WAS LOVED BY ALL HE ALWAYS
HAD A SMILE ON HIS FACE AND-
WHEN HE WAS UP SAID HE WOULD
GREATEST. DRAW AND SEE STEEP
ALL ARE REALLY NEED YOU ON THIS
THING BUT HE WOULD DO IT. WITH
A SENSE OF. LOVE IN HIS HEART
IN THE WAS NEVER REALLY ANGERED
AYE AYE SOL MAD ONE TIME AND- I
GOT A LAUGH BUT- I GUESS MY
LAST MOST MEMORABLE. MOMENT
WITH MR TO CLOSE SHE WAS
SHORTLY AFTER WE CAME BACK TO
MAY. AND I WAS COMING INTO THE
BUILDING ON ON THE OLD STREET
SIDE AND HE WAS WALKING OUT.
AND HIT THIS BEAUTIFUL BLUE
THREE PIECE SUIT ON IS A STATE
OLE HOW DO YOU LIKE MY SUIT. IS
ONE OF MY NEW ONES AND HE
LOOKED SO WELL IN THESE HAVE
LOST A LITTLE WEIGHT. IS BUT-
I'M LOOKING GOOD I SEE MISTER
POLICE TO YOUR AND FIVE USES.
CLEAR YOUR CALENDAR WE'RE GOING
TO PLAY SOME GOLF I SAID OKAY
MISTER PROCESSES WE'RE GONNA DO
IT HERE IS NO WE'RE GOING TO GO
DOWN TO MY HOUSE WE'RE GOING TO
DO IT SO. I ASSUMED WAS GOOD A
CALL. LATER AFTER THAT AND SAYS
HEY. WE GOT A WORKING THINGS
OUT OF TO LEGISLATION HE'S AS I
WANT TO GET BACK TO YOU AND
THEN ALL SAID. I DIDN'T HEAR
FROM HIM. FOR WHILE ONLY TO
FIND OUT THAT. HE WAS NOT DOING
TOO WELL AND A FORMER
COLLEAGUE- BRUTAL TO RECALL
ANOTHER AMAZING INDIVIDUAL.
CALL ME YESTERDAY TO LET ME
KNOW THAT. HE PASSED AND IT'S
SO IRONIC YESTERDAY I HAD A
THREE PIECE SUIT ALL. THOUGHT
ABOUT MR POLICY BECAUSE AGAIN
WHOSE IS A GENUINELY NICE HUMAN
BEING AND I WISH. WE GET IN
BODY THAT WHICH HE HAD. JUSTICE
LOVING SPIRIT BUT THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING HE WAS A LOVING
HUSBAND AND FATHER HE TOOK
GREAT PRIDE IN HIS KIDS HIS SON
BILLY YOU SHARED WITH ME THE
WORLD SERIES STORY AND ALL THE
AGES HE HE DELIGHTED IN JUST
BEING A PARENT AND A LYFT AN
EXPERIENCED. KIDS SUCCESS AND-
I'M JUST GOING TO SOME AROUND
THIS TOWN HE MADE THIS PLACE A
BETTER PLACE. HE MADE THIS
INDUSTRY A MORE HONORABLE
RESPECTABLE BUSINESS AGAIN IT
WAS AN ABOUT PARTY IT WAS AN
ABOUT GENDER WITH ABOUT THE
WHEN YOU ARE THEN AND YOU KNOW
YOU TECH CHARACTER THAT. MATT
HE WAS A FORMER ATHLETE AS WE
ALL KNOW PLAY PROFESSIONAL
SPORTS AND JUST A GIANT OF A
MAN BUT A WONDERFUL LOVING
HUMAN BEING AND HE'S GOING TO
BE SORELY MESSED SAN I ASKED
THE JOURNEY MEMORY. THANK YOU
CENTER BRADFORD. IS THERE A NO
OTHER BUSINESS ATKINS THE DESK
IS CLEAR. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT LET ME ADD MY-
CONDOLENCES AND RESPECT TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DUPLICITOUS.
FAMILY INTO HIS MEMORY YOU KNOW
IT'S NOT OFTEN WE SEE THE KIND
OF RESPECT EXHIBITED BY. BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE BUT WHEN A
WHEN A GENTLEMAN IS A GENTLEMAN
A PERSON IS A GOOD PERSON IT'S
REFLECTED IN PEOPLE IN COLLEGES
SO LET ME ADD MY FAX. I TO HIM
AND HIS FAMILY. ARE COLLEAGUES-
I HOPE YOU ALL HAD HOME. TO
SPEND TIME WITH FAMILY. AND
THIS NEXT WEEK THE ONE WEEK
THAT THE SENATE WILL BE IN
RECESS IS. IMPORTANT THAT'S
WHEN WE COME BACK WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO IN
A DIFFICULT TIME- AS IT RELATES
TO WHAT'S GOING ON IN IN OUR
WORLD. CERTAINLY IN OUR COUNTRY
AND IN OUR STATE WITH THE
PANDEMIC- WHEN WE COME BACK
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE ABOUT THREE
WEEKS IN WHICH TO. HEAR SIMPLY
BILLS AND THERE WERE DO IT RISK.
A PHYSICAL. THING DOES DISTANCE
THING. THE RULE THAT WE PUT IN
PLACE TO KEEP US AND OUR HAVE
SAFE BUT WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK
TO DO. AND I SAY ALL THAT
BECAUSE I IF YOU REALLY TAKE
THE TIME TO REST THIS NEXT WEEK.
BECAUSE WE ARE BEING CHALLENGED
IN WAYS WE NEVER HAVE BEFORE AS
A LEGISLATURE- WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT JULY AUGUST HOLDS IN TERMS
OF THE PANDEMIC. WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT IT HOLDS AND- THE
ADDITIONAL REVENUES WE MAY HAVE
OR NOT HAVE BEEN. OF LOOKING.
AT A AT THE JULY FIFTEENTH
REVENUES SO THAT WE CAN HOLD
TRUE. TO WHAT WE NEED TO DO ON
THE BUDGET OUTLOOK MOVING FOR.
AND THEN WE HAVE LET'S. PLAY
**** SO. I TRULY WANT YOU TO
GET A BREAK AND TO REST BECAUSE
YOU HAVE EARNED IT YOU DESERVE
IT YOU WORKED INCREDIBLY HARD-
A WE MAY DEBATE ISSUES ON THIS
FLOOR BUT THE RESPECT WE HAVE
FOR EACH OTHER IN THE WORK. YOU
TAKE WITH YOU. JEWISH FAMILIES
AND- I WILL SEE YOU BACK HERE
ON MONDAY JULY THIRTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY AT TWO PM BE SAFE
BE HEALTHY BE HAPPY. THANK YOU
SENATOR ATKINS THE SENATE WILL
BE IN RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY
PM AT WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
PLACED WE WILL RECONVENE ON
MONDAY JULY THIRTEENTH AT TWO
PM HAVE A SAFE AND SANE FOURTH
OF JULY MEMBERS.